the chair recognizes his member from
auburn representative osborne moves the
house adjourned from the session to may
12 2022. are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye those opposed
nay
the eyes have it and the house is
adjourned the house will attend to a
prayer by house chaplain reverend bob
stewart pastor of saint paul's united
methodist church in manchester
good morning
let us be in a spirit of prayer
a loving god
we remember those that have lost their
lives from gun violence
in recent weeks
we remember the children and teachers
in uvalde texas
whose lives have been cut short
we remember those who were shopping for
groceries in a supermarket in buffalo
new york
when hate
reared its ugly head
we paused this morning for a moment of
silence
as we honor them
and the families left behind to grieve
oh gracious lord you are the alpha
and the omega
the first and the last
the beginning and the end
we praise your name and honor your
presence in our lives
on this memorial day weekend oh lord we
pray with gratitude for those who have
served our country through military
service
we thank you for their sacrifice and for
the freedom we enjoy that they fought so
valiantly to uphold
we honor those who lost their lives and
pray
that you would comfort those who still
mourn them
remind them that they are not alone
that you are with them always
a holy one as we near the summer months
and this house goes into recess
i pray that you keep each member and
leader and their respective families
healthy and safe
until we gather together again to resume
the business for this great state of new
hampshire
today we seek your guiding hand
as we handle the business on the agenda
of the house today
be with each representative and leader
so they can make effective and
meaningful decisions
for those they represent
be with us throughout this day and lord
make this a fruitful day
it is in your glory and honor
we pray
amen
chair recognized as a member of muhudsen
representative kim rice will lead us in
the pledge of allegiance
the chair recognizes granite statesman
who will now sing our national anthem
oh
[Music]
strikes and
and the rock
[Music]
still is
oh say does that star spangled
[Music]
me
[Applause]
the house will attend to request for
leaves of absence
mr speaker the day illness
representatives birch cleaver connors
ellis gorg mary griffin popper major
o'brien rollins
the day important business
representatives binford cody gorski
harvey mclean mills oxenham sanborn
sweeney
tarousian van vincent the day illness in
the family representatives cahill
elliott nelson and porter
these leaves of absence shall be
granules otherwise voted by the house
house to attend to the introduction of
guests
mr speaker please welcome jen morton
guest of representatives megan murray
and value
katie patenrill robin dougherty and
catherine collins guests of
representative notter jeannette valle
regine and sandra martin guests of
representative lebranch
joni marley janssen colton daxton and
sierra smirthwaite guest of
representative yokela
wolfram ben vanshkowen guest of
representative healy
the honorable fred davis former member
from nashua and beck kelly guest of
representative adjutant
lieutenant colonel stewart sheller u.s
marine corps retired
brigadier general don baldock u.s army
retired and his wife sharon bolduc guest
of representative boyd
fourth grade students from stratford
school guests of the house they are with
us in the gallery today
welcome to the new hampshire house
[Applause]
[Music]
the house will attend to the consent
calendar of comedia console reports on
senate bills
mr speaker there are no bills to be
removed from the consent calendar
are there any bills to be removed from
the consent calendar
[Music]
adoption of the consent calendar on
senate bills are ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it
and the senate bills are adopted
house will attend to the regular
calendar of committee a conference
reports on senate bills
chair recognizes the clerk
mr speaker message
mr speaker senate bill 200 apportioning
congressional
griffin moves and districts adopt the
committee conference report
is speaking again
president barbara griffin moves that we
adopt the committee of confidence report
on senate bill 200
chair recognizes representative byrd
thank you
mr speaker
i have had the privilege
and i mean privilege to be elected six
times
from goffstown ware and deering
mr speaker i have never missed a house
vote
in the 12 years i've been here
house will be in order
i sit in the people's seat mr speaker
it's not my seat
i've never forgot that mr speaker
it is the people that elected me
is the seat that i sit in
with that said mr speaker
goffstown has sent me here today to vote
no
on senate bill 200.
senate bill 200 is not good for
goffstown
many voters in town have talked with me
and said that they have been with cd1
for ever
that they've been there
and as far as they remember they've been
in cd1
mr
speaker we now have a new senate seat in
goffstown a new hampshire senate seat
and that is
goffstown hooksett manchester ward 1
candia raymond
and they are happy with that new senate
seat mr speaker and they would like to
remain in cd1
mr speaker we have passed house bill 52
and i understand that it's on your desk
somewheres and we could find it and blow
the dust off it
and send it to the governor's desk for
his signature
and no court involvement would have to
happen
house bill 52 is available to us
if this fails
for that reason mr speaker
you will be forever
in my heart if you join me in pressing
the bright red button
as i will be doing mr speaker and i
would like a division vote
thank you mr speaker
i recognize representative abramson
mr speaker i originally
spoke against this bill it was changed
in the state senate and i was going to
come
here today and speak against it again
however in the the spirit of compromise
and recognizing that certain changes
were made to make the district
map more compact
uh using a shorter line making it more
even and i think more fair and putting
the voters back in control
i'm i will be voting in favor of this so
i wore the red the wrong color today i
apologize for that
next time i'll remember to wear a green
shirt
thank you please press the green button
geo recognizes representative bergeron
thank you mr speaker i rise today in
opposition to the committee of
conference report on senate bill 200.
during the redistricting process the
house special committee on redistricting
held listing sessions in all 10 counties
and conducted a number of public
hearings on redistricting proposals
at no time did members of the committee
hear calls for the congressional
districts to undergo radical changes
the committee of conference report
proposes moving 34 cities and towns from
one district to another with a total
population of 314
755 people being moved between districts
it places new hampshire's three largest
cities into district two
which will disenfranchise less populated
and more rural areas of the state
proponents have argued that this plan is
a good one because there is a population
difference between the two congressional
districts of only 53 people but the
house has already rejected a proposal
with a difference of just 51 people
proponents have argued that it doesn't
matter if our two congressional
representatives would now be living in
the same district because a candidate
for congress does not need to live in
the district in which he is a candidate
but the last person who ran for congress
who did not live in the district in
which he was running received less than
two percent of the vote
the proposed plan shifts the first
congressional district about three
percentage points towards republicans in
the second congressional district about
three percentage points toward democrats
by trying to pack republican votes into
one district the proposal makes the
other district more democratic
new hampshire is a purple state we have
a republican governor who carried both
congressional districts in previous
elections and we have democratic
congressional representatives in each of
the two districts
over the past 10 years the legislature
has shifted back and forth between
democratic and republican control
the districts have been competitive the
people of new hampshire deserve to keep
both of their congressional districts
competitive there is no overriding
interest in making such massive changes
to the congressional districts i would
ask therefore that you vote against this
report by pressing the red note button
thank you
mike
j recognizes representative stephen
smith
thank you mr speaker
i rise today to support the committee of
conference report
sometimes how things look depends on
where you're standing when you look at
them i live in cd too
contrary to what you heard before i have
been advocating for radical change
throughout this process because it
doesn't look great from where i live
about a third of the way up the vermont
border
the current
horrifically gerrymandered map that we
have
reaches all the way down under cd1 over
to atkinson and then up to canada
what kind of sense does that make
it's the district of the rest of us
i get that the bulk of the population is
packed into the bottom right corner of
the state and it's probably going to
stay that way but can't we do better
this map does better it gets rid of the
ridiculous fingers that we have reaching
across the street the state creates a
more sensible shape and i know we're not
allowed to use props but try to
visualize this with me
turn the map that we have 90 degrees
clockwise what do you get on the left
you have the horseshoe or starfleet
emblem that everybody derided on the
other map that we passed it's not quite
as big and that's because it is joined
by the all the other little horseshoes
to the right i mean you drive towards
vermont for 45 minutes or an hour
depending on the traffic you bang a uae
and head back to the coast for a half
hour
does that make sense
just because it's always been that way
should we support it no
every ten years it is the job of the
legislature to come up with a plan
not figure out if the old plan's okay
can we maybe you know just tweak it a
little but to come up with a plan that
makes sense today
i heard somebody say the original
districts have been pretty much the same
since the 1800s
when we were moving stuff around the
state by steam train horse and wagon
and and riverboats come on the state has
changed this plan makes sense what does
it do we don't reach around city under
cd1
all the way to atkinson we have a more
sensible east-west barrier i'd like to
see districts that were almost east-west
i didn't get that
but we didn't have a step towards making
better progress
so for those reasons that's why i'm
going to vote for this today it's a step
in the right direction the districts are
certainly competitive
we're not supposed to talk about the
political stuff i'm going to
if you take the results of the 2020
election and put it in here
mr mowers still would have lost so this
is into trying to stilt it to cheat to
win to give the republicans a guaranteed
victory that is not the case
52 is dead
your job today is to press a green
button or a red button here's the only
difference between those two buttons
you can
press the green button and fulfill your
constitutional obligation to redistrict
or you can press the red button and this
very day some hired gun from out of
state that doesn't know new hampshire is
going to start drawing him out i'm not
going to let that happen and i hope you
join me in not letting that happen thank
you mr speaker
house will be in order
representative doucet has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded
members will take your seats this is
going to be a roll call vote
and turn on your voting stations
so
the motion before us is the committee
conference report on senate bill 200.
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative bergeron
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this proposal would move
23 percent of the state's population and
34 cities and towns between districts
and if i know that the people of new
hampshire want both of their
congressional districts to remain
competitive
and if i know that placing the state's
three largest cities in the same
district will disenfranchise the less
populated and more rural areas of the
state
would i then press the red no button to
reject this committee of conference
report
chair recognizes representative osborne
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
so if i know that uh today we are at the
end of the road we've got no more
room left to maneuver in this process
if i know that if we did not pass this
map today
that some
court is going to be doing it for us
would i now press
the green button
the motion before us
is the uh ought to pass motion committee
of the senate bill 200 and committee of
confidence report it's a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you approach you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative spain
it's not going to work now thank you
you're here
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will tend to stay to the vote
106 house will be in order 176 voting
171 voting a committed report is adopted
chair recognizes the clerk for a senate
message
committee conference
senate bill 238 relatives to special
education services and charter public
schools
representative ladd moves we adopt the
committee of conference report are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it the
committee conference report is adopted
at this time
i'd like the dean of the house to come
up
and take over for a few bills
[Applause]
thank you
thank you all very much
[Applause]
if you hear a lot of knees knocking
teach everyone you know it's where it's
[Applause]
the coming recognizes the clerk
senate bill 271 relative to the burgess
biopower facility
representative
moves that we wreck
that we
that we recognize the report
and concur are you ready for the
question
all in favor say aye
all opposed say no
the eyes have it
i'll recognize clerk
thank you madam speaker senate bill 353
relative to the education professional
standards board
representative loud
moves that we recognize the
conference report
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed say no
the eyes have it
[Music]
you
ready i recognize the clerk thank you
madam speaker senate bill 366 requiring
an audit of ballots cast in the 2022
primary and general election
representative barbara griffin
moves that we accept the report
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed say no
the eyes have it
i'm going to return this to the speaker
before i
powerpoint
[Applause]
in recognition
the honorable laura penalakis
whereas the honorable laura penalakis
was first elected to the new hampshire
house of representatives in november
and has subsequently been reelected
every two years since
whereas the honorable laura panalakis
also served alongside nine governors
12 speakers of the house and thousands
of fellow state representatives and
whereas
a driving force behind the order of
women legislators
for years laura penalakis helped raise
thousands of dollars for charity and
whereas throughout her tenure in the
house she has served as chair and
ranking member of the criminal justice
of public safety committee committee on
fish and game and family law
whereas
serving her 22nd term in the new
hampshire house of representatives she
is the dean of the house one of the
longest serving state legislators in the
united states of america
therefore be it declared that the new
hampshire house of representatives
honors and celebrates our dean the
honorable laura penalakis on her
well-earned retirement from this house
and be it further declared by virtue of
my signature inscribed below the new
hampshire house of representatives must
publicly thank and honor
laura panalakis for the dedication to
the city of portsmouth and state of new
hampshire and offer further thanks to
her family for their support of her
community involvement
[Applause]
chair recognizes the the member from
pentecore
thank you thank you mr speaker
it's incredible to think that laura
panalakis has been serving in this house
for 44 years
just think of the lucrative legislative
pension she'll be receiving
amazing
i knew laura penalakis when i came to
the house in 2004
but i really got to know her in the year
terry norelli was the speaker of the
house then
and she appointed me to be chair of the
house criminal justice committee and
appointed laura as the vice chair
and if anybody were to ask me what was
the happiest two years
of your life here in the new hampshire
house
not the proudest that'd be 2018 but the
happiest
it was that 2008 session
and what made it even better being on
criminal justice is
my good friend and mentor david welch
was the ranking member of the committee
back then
and that's when the three of us decided
that neither side democrats republicans
would caucus
and we shook hands on it and terry
narelly would give us heck for not
caucusing but
we said we'll take up the bills as they
come first one to raise a hand that's
who's recognized it will vote on the
emotion
and somehow it worked back then
laura
and david were such mentors to me
and i know if not for the advice and
counsel and guidance they gave me
as a new member a fairly new member of
the house and chairing
a committee i never would have ever
risen to be a speaker of this body
it all started in that 2008 session
and with laura it was almost like we
were good cop in bad cop
i tend to be a little more diplomatic
than my good friend from portsmouth
and i can remember before we had a
committee hearing a criminal justice and
there was one person that came before
the committee
who would represent a
contingency and speak on every bill that
affected that group that he represented
and would go on he's a little bit
pompous too to tell you the truth
and so he gave this long dissertation
why we the committee should do one thing
or another
and laura said to me i got a question
for him i said i recognized laura she
says
why the hell aren't you wearing an
orange badge
she says you're a lobbyist you should be
registered as a lobbyist you hear all
that and then she gives the guy in the
pajama just speechless
but that was laura
you always know what she thought
you might not like want to hear what she
thought but you knew what she thought
i read an article in the new hampshire
magazine several years ago it was after
a former representative
from executive council from the north
country
um ray burton passed away
it was a wonderful article and in the
article it told all about the wonderful
things that executive councillor burton
did
and one of the last sentences in the
article was that ray burton was the
second longest
elected official in the state of new
hampshire
and then there was a period they never
mentioned who was
the first
longest serving elected official in the
state of new hampshire
and that was our friend laura panalakis
and all of us especially those in small
towns that have members that have served
seems like forever on select boards and
library trustees and so many other
positions
to think
since
12 14 15 years laura has been the
longest elected official in the granite
state
the house isn't going to be the same
next session
we're losing a lot of good friends
who wouldn't decided not to run for
various reasons
but to me to have laura not sitting
there and for one session i was her seat
mate in division one
and
it's not going to be the same
but because of her and also for david
i'm always going to have those wonderful
memories of serving on the criminal
justice committee with them in 2008 and
that's something i'll never forget
and all i can say is laura i love you
and thank you and thank you to my friend
david welch
um
my life is so much better happy knowing
you and all the help that both of you
have given me
thank you and god bless new hampshire
[Applause]
without objection the remarks of the
representative will be printed in a
permanent journal
recognizes the clerk for a committee
conference report
mr speaker senate bill 381 establishing
an office of the advocate for special
education
representative ladd moves we adopt the
conference report are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and their report is
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for a
senate committee confidence report mr
speaker senate bill 401 making
appropriations to the department of
transportation for local highway aid
into the body worn and dashboard camera
fund permitting the department of
transportation to operate dash cameras
and fleet vehicles and relative to the
duration of unemployment benefits
senator roy moves we adopt the committee
a conference report are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
your eyes have it the report is adopted
chair recognizes the clerk for a further
senate conference report
mr speaker senate bill 420 establishing
an extraordinary need grant for schools
and relative to eligibility for the
education tax credit
presenter vlad moves as we adopt the
committee of conference report are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee conference
report is adopted chair recognizes the
clerk for a furnace senate committee
conference report mr speaker senate bill
445 relative to the broadband matching
grant initiative
representative emrick moves we adopt the
committee of confidence report are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee conference
report is adopted
foreign
chair recognizes a clerk for a senate
message
mr speaker the senate has adopted the
recommendation of the committee of
conference to which was referred the
following title bills house bill 230
relative to child day care monitoring
visits and the appeals process for child
day care providers house bill 355
relative to kino house bill 1011
relative to criminal mischief house bill
1130 relative to restroom access for
persons with certain medical conditions
and relative to the procedure for
obtaining a marriage license house bill
1439 relative to health care visitation
policies
those bills are on the consent calendar
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay you guys have it and
those bills are adopted
the chair recognizes the clerk for a
further senate message
for what reason to remember rise
to make a motion
state your motion
mr speaker
i move that the house rules be so far
suspended as to allow for late drafting
introduction waving of public hearing
report from committee and if passed for
immediate third reading motion
irrespective of deadlines for a bill
relative to background checks
house will be in order also be in order
the motion is in order
members recognize to speak to a motion
colleagues
since the first hearing in on january
26th
and the house vote on march 17th
on house bill 1668
there have been 41 more mass shootings i
propose that as the elected leaders of
this state it is imperative
that we act and act now
to curb the flow of blood running
towards us
it is the purpose and intent
of the general court
to require commercial firearm sales in
new hampshire and it for them to be
processed through a licensed firearm
dealer who will conduct a background
check and create a new record of each
sale
i propose that the general court
believes this law will protect public
safety by helping to keep firearms out
of the hands of felons domestic abusers
and those adjudicated to be mentally ill
the majority of our constituents in fact
actually it's a little more than 65
percent of granite staters support
this gun violence prevention measure
we must act now
we cannot wait
and i urge my colleagues to vote yes
on a suspension of the rules to
reintroduce a background check bill
jay i recognize representative roy
thank you mr thank you mr speaker
we should not
ever
use tragedy to push legislation
[Music]
the house will be in order it has been
said
by people
do not let a good tragedy go to waste
i suggest to you today
that the people of this state have
spoken over and over and over
on what they want for gun legislation
and if we were to
move for new legislation the people of
the state have a right to be heard in a
hearing process
they do not want bills snuck in at the
last minute
and
with no hearing
and it's just not going to happen and
we're not going to do it we will
comply with the hearing process of this
house and not
force legislation on the people
even when we were in the minority and it
went to the governor it was vetoed
so everybody has spoken on it now next
year we're happy to address it again and
maybe it'll change
but
we will not be throwing aside the
process we use to make
laws and that is that
this
house will be in order does the member
yield to questions
remember does not yield
representative byrd has requested a roll
calls that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
so
the motion before us is the rules
suspension
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
altruller for a parliamentary inquiry
if i know
that granite staters
are in shock
have demanded action
have reached out and cried in anguish in
support of the dead
slain
children
grocery store shoppers
worshipers
across our nation
and if i know
there have been more mass shootings in
than there have been days
in the calendar
and if i know
we are
only we are only
one of 16 states
so far
in just the first five months to have
not
experienced a mass shooting and that
doesn't make us special
nor does it make us house will be in
order
i'm sorry perhaps i could be a little
louder if i know that we are only one of
16 states that have not experienced a
mass shooting so far in 2022
and if i
know that stepping over the bodies of
dead children is an unacceptable way
the member will suspend state your point
of order
mr speaker this is a question to you
thank you for hearing me
this sounds like a horrible
perhaps unintended invitation to
disaster in the state of new hampshire
and i that's
it's a question that's
that's that's not a that's not a point
of order well i'm my point of order
would be
under these circumstances
can a
speaker's speech be suspended
period
the member is delivering a parliamentary
inquiry
[Music]
and she is i'm sure she is going to wrap
up very soon
thank you very much
the member will continue
thank you mr speaker
i'll repeat my last two phrases and i
will wrap up no i was talked over if i
might be
this is a parliamentary inquiry not a
speech if i know
that stepping over the bodies of dead
children is an unacceptable way
to live
and if i know
the house will be in order
finally if i know
that we can do hard things
and we can make a change so that we
don't have to live like this will i now
press the green button for the state of
new hampshire has asked us to
chair
the house will be in order
the house will be in order members take
your state
the chair recognizes representative
burke for parliamentary inquiry
thank you
mr speaker
new hampshire
is one of the safest states
in the nation
oh i'm sorry you are correct
thank you
if i know
if i know new hampshire is one of the
safest states in the nation
and if i also know
many years we even beat canada in being
safe
would i now
vote
read
so this can end today thank you mr
speaker
the motion before us is suspension of
the rolls
this roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
if all members president opportunity to
vote also attend the state of the vote
under the 63 voting a 188 voting a the
motion fails
[Music]
recognize the clerk for a further senate
message
mr speaker the senate has adopted the
recommendation of the committee
conference to which he will refer the
following title bills house bill 103
establishing a dental benefit under the
state medicaid program house bill 1066
requiring the commissioner of the
department of environmental services to
prepare a plan relative to cyber
cyanobacterial blooms in new hampshire
house bill 1106 establishing a
commission to study recruiting members
of the armed forces and the commission
on demographic trends house bill 1109
relative to the authority of the city or
town to limit the use or operation of an
ohrv on certain ways house bill 1256
relative to positions within the
department of military affairs and
veteran services making an appropriation
to the state regenerative manufacturing
workforce development fund and adjusting
and making an appropriation relative to
the medicaid reimbursement rates for
ambulance services house bill 1293
relative to the design of sewage and
waste disposal systems for a person's
own domicile relative to water well and
sewage waste disposal systems house bill
1299 relative to the process for the
importation of wildlife and creating an
appeal process for denials of permits
house bill 1333
relative to the definition of a way for
the purposes of driving under the
influence of drugs or liquor and
administrative license suspensions house
bill 1397 relative to the length of
terms for rockingham county officers in
relative to the gun stock area
commissioners house bill 1421 relative
to lead in school drinking water
house bill 1466 relative to the
off-label use of prescription drugs in
relative to pharmacy prescriptions house
bill 1487 relative to the procedure for
withdrawal from the vaccine registry
house bill 1503
adopting the uniform commercial code
relative to the controllable electronic
records relative to exempting
the developer seller or facilitator of
the exchange of an open block change
token from certain security laws and
establishing state procurement policies
intended to promote the use of american
materials hospital 1547 relative to
perfluorinated chemical remediation and
soil and procedures for certain
hazardous waste generators house bill
1627 establishing an education freedom
account program administrator in the
department of education making
appropriation therefore house bill 2022
relative to the 10-year highway
transportation plan and house bill 1221
relative to the rate of the business
profits tax in relative to payment by
the state or political subdivisions of
an amount equal to a portion of
retirement system contributions of
political subdivision employers
the chair recognizes the clerk for a
committee conference report
mr speaker house bill 103 establishing a
dental benefit program under the state
medicaid program
presenter mark pearson moves that we
adopt and is recognized
he's not recognized
are you ready for the question
who requested a role president sylvia
requested a roll calls that's officially
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take their seats
is
so uh
the motion before us
on house bill 103
is to adopt a committee report
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes
chair recognized representative sylvia
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know
that medicare was a promise made
to seniors
and if i know that
that has been ever expanding to cover
more and more
if i know
that we should focus on
our seniors take care of them as
promised
would i then press the red button
also be in order chair recognize
representative mark pearson for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that
expending some money for preventative
oral work will eliminate
much more expensive payouts in the
future in other words change your oil
regularly or you'll have to spend to
change your engine
if i also know that the house voted this
bill out by a 137
vote margin recently
and if i know that many states blue red
and purple have voted for bills very
similar to this
would i not now press the green button
the motion before us is the adoption of
the committee economics report in house
bill 103 it's a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you oppose you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
the vote
246 voting yeah 105 voting a committee
conference report is adopted
for what reason does a member rise
i have a question for the chair state
your question thank you very much mr
speaker mr speaker i wonder if it is
relevant
for members of this body to understand
the difference between medicare and
medicaid
that's not a question a question to the
chair
for what reason does a member rise
for a motion
state your motion
mr speaker if i rise in the spirit of
disagreeing without being disagreeable
i would like to motion to place the
remarks in the permanent journal of the
rule suspension
debate
the question before us is to place the
remarks of the debate on the rules
suspension in the permanent journal is
that
am i correct
a division has been requested
members will take your seats
so
motion before us is to place the remarks
of the debate
on the
in the permanent journal
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you post you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
representative shapiro
all members president had an opportunity
to vote household 10 state of the vote
183 voting yay 167 voting a the remarks
will be printed
chair recognizes the clerk
for a further senate message on
committee a conference
mr speaker house bill 1066 requiring the
commissioner of the department of
environmental services to prepare a plan
relative to cyanobacterial blooms in new
hampshire
senator harm's moves we concur with the
committee of conference report are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee
conference report is adopted chair
recognize the clerk for a further senate
message
mr speaker house bill 1106 establishing
a commission to study recruiting members
of the armed forces and the commission
on demographic trends
president
moves we adopt the committee of
conference report are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee conference
report is adopted chair recognizes the
clerk for a further senate message mr
speaker house bill 1109 relative to the
authority of a city or town to limit the
use or operation of an ohrv on certain
waves
present harms mobility adopt a committee
conference report are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee conference
report is adopted chair recognized the
clerk for a further committee uh
conference report house bill 1221
relative to the rate of business profits
tax and relative to payment by the state
to political subdivisions of an amount
equal to a portion of retirement system
contributions of political subdivision
employers
senator brown removes we adopt the
committee of conference report are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee conference
report is adopted chair recognize the
clerk for a further senate message
mr speaker house bill 1256 relative to
positions within the department of
military affairs and veterans services
making an appropriation to the state
regenerative manufacturing workforce
development fund and adjusting and
making an appropriation relative to the
medicaid reimbursement rates of
ambulance services
senator bell disarro moves we adopt the
committee of confidence report are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee conference
report is adopted
chair recognize the clerk for a further
senate message
mr speaker house bill 1293
relative to the design of sewage or
waste disposal systems of for a person's
own domicile and relative to water well
and sewage or waste disposal systems
jim dolan moves we adopt the committee
conference report are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee
conference report is adopted chair
recognized the clerk for
further senate message
mr speaker 1290 house bill 1299 relative
to the process for the importation of
wildlife and creating an appeal process
for denials of permits
moves we adopt the committee conference
report are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee conference
report is adopted jericho is a clerk for
a further senate message
mr speaker the senate excuse me house
bill 1333 relative to the definition of
a way for the purposes of driving under
the influence of drugs or liquor and
administrative license suspensions
moves we adopt the committee conference
report are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye close opposed
nay
chair is in doubt this will be a
division vote
members will be in your seats
this will be a division vote
to clarify
the uncertainty of the voice vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're posed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
i need a thumbs up
represent pluto o'brien
representative
while members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the vote
154 voting a 193 voting a committee of
conference report fails
chair recognizes the clerk for a further
senate message
mr speaker house bill 1397 relative to
the length of terms for rockingham
county officers and relative to the gun
stock area commission
senator dolan moves will you concur are
you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee
conference report is adopted chair
recognized the clerk for a further
senate message
house bill 1421 relative to lead in
school drinking water
representative lads moods we concur
adopt with the uh the comedian
conference report are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
your eyes have it committee confidence
report is adopted do you recognize the
clerk for a further senate message
mr speaker house bill 1466 relative to
the off-label use of prescription drugs
and relative to pharmacy prescriptions
present of leon moves we adopt the
committee conference report are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee committee
confidence report is adopted chair
recognize the clerk for further senate
message
house bill 1487 relative to the
procedure for withdrawal from the
vaccine registry
presented leon moves we adopt the
committee conference report are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee
conference report is adopted chair
recognizes the clerk for further senate
message
mr speaker house bill 1503 adopting the
uniform commercial code relative to
controllable electronic records relative
to exempting the developer seller or
facilitator of the exchange of an open
blockchain token from certain securities
laws and establishing state procurement
policies intended to promote the use of
american materials
senate hunt moves we adopt the committee
of conference report are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee conference
report is adopted
chair recognize the clerk for further
senate message
mr speaker house bill 1547 relative to
perfluorinated chemical remediation in
soil and procedures for certain
hazardous waste generators
senator pearl moves we adopt the
committee conference report are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee a conference
report is adopted chair recognizes the
clerk for a further senate message
house bill 1627 establishing
an education freedom account program
administrator in the department of
education and making an appropriation
it's in therefore vlad moves we adopt
the committee conference report are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee
conference report is adopted chair
recognized the clerk for further senate
message
house bill 2022 relative to the 10-year
transportation plan
representative stephen smith move we
adopt the committee conference report
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee
conference report is adopted
also be in order
the senate still has four bills that we
haven't received yet
so what we're going to do now
is to take up uh we have a numerous
committee
committee of
unanimous consensus
so we're going to take those up right
now
jr recognizes representative lange
i believe you're going to talk about the
softball
yes i am surprised i'm going to talk
about the softball game
thank you mr speaker thank you members
for indulging me this truly is the last
time i'll speak about softball today or
this this session
so the final game score was
16-3 congratulations to the house
democrats for the win
[Applause]
in the game we saw representative soti
hit a home run which was very cool but
on top of that not to be outdone
we saw representative willem also hit a
home run and not only that he hit a
second home run for a grand slam
congratulations sir
well these feats of athleticism are
noteworthy it is truly the camaraderie
and the non-partisan shown during the
game
what is truly inspiring
and let's remember why we did it
it wasn't about the score
we collected over 400 pounds of food for
new hampshire's needy as part of this
process
we raised over 3 200
that will support the homeless veterans
transitional housing program
a domestic violence victim shelter
program
and lastly as program to support parents
with this disabled children
i want to thank
everyone who donated and the house
members who played great job i'll see
you next year on the field thank you
again members
where's where's our democratic coach mr
migliori where mr mcguire where is he
there he is so you get to hang this
wonderful trophy over in the minority
office next year enjoy
[Applause]
the chair recognizes representative
o'brien
for unanimous consent
thank you mr speaker
may is foster care awareness month
thank you for this opportunity to talk
about this topic and why it is important
to me
according to the u s department of
health and human service figures from
2019 there were
1225 foster youth in our state and of
those
278 were adopted or just over 20 percent
while that may sound like a terrible
rate the fact that is that you know
reunification with family is usually the
goal of foster care and most kids in
foster care are not available for
adoption most parents who have children
in foster care have not had their
parental rights terminated
the hope is that the parents will be
able to achieve a better and healthier
environment for their children and then
the family can be reunited
each child in foster care has a very
individual and complex story
whether our own personal feelings and
opinions are about the
whatever our own personal feelings and
opinions about the foster care system in
general the reality is that it is a
necessity for these children
it is a reality that cannot always be
accurately predicted at the start of
their life
a family that may start out looking
stable on the outside may later need
assistance being able to care for their
children and that may include foster
care of some kind
until we can eliminate the factors that
go into parents being able
to best care for their children the
foster care system is here to stay
despite all the strong emotions that
come up where whenever we hear of the
mischie treatment of children within the
system
we have to get this right
we invest so much in our children both
personally and as a society in funding
their education and well-being that it's
bad fiscal sense to give up on any child
i once had dinner with the swiss
ambassador to the united states and we
discussed one of my favorite topics
vocational education in switzerland
versus vocational education in the
united states and societal attitudes
surrounding all aspects of it yes
i happened to read a book about it
before i happened to meet him
he told me that since they do not have
any natural resources you know except
for tourism
to speak of they consider their children
to be their most precious natural
resource and that has always resonated
with me
we cannot risk throwing people away or
having them feel thrown away and
unwanted
a child a child's worth and value is not
and should not be dependent upon a few
people who are able or unwilling to care
for them or who simply don't want them
whether they are related by blood or not
when children feel unvalued rejected and
thrown away this creates dysfunction
that reverberates all over our society
and into the next generations it's not
just unhealthy it's a sort of
slow-motion societal suicide we simply
cannot afford to treat people this way
there are many wonderful foster parents
and they are worthy of our utmost praise
and respect and i thank you to all who
have become foster and adoptive parents
for all the right reasons i've met you
and some of you are with us in this
great hall today
[Applause]
i have i have more but we also have time
since we're waiting for the senate under
the best of circumstances foster care is
a sort of culture shock it takes
adjustment that can be hard
when they're already when there is
already a lot of baggage
to bring to the new home so to speak
when foster care doesn't work out for a
child if they feel unwanted or if they
feel the providers are not in it for the
right reasons it's the end of the line
where do you go after that trust is gone
and it isn't coming back
you feel like all hope is gone
my social workers
looked for a placement for me for months
and months but few people wanted
teenagers teenagers have baggage and i
didn't have much at the time literally
and figuratively just one black trash
trash bag as an aside a friend suggested
that since we are unaware of any flag
that is used for foster care awareness
that a trash bag be used
ouch
but it makes the point
all these years later i'm still feeling
pretty bad about this and maybe i may be
a big important state representative now
which is a little bit of a joke because
you know but this perceived earlier
rejection by my entire community lingers
and i know my life would be different
now had i had more confidence in myself
early on
i'm sure someone would have wanted me if
they knew me and if they knew i was a
nice kid if they knew i had never been
in trouble with the police that my
teachers liked me and
but none of that mattered at all
it felt like none of that mattered
because before the world saw me as any
of those good things they saw me as a
kid
as a kid from a family with with
problems and an at-risk kid
and i'll be honest with you there was
rage and there was anger and there was
extreme jealousy of the other kids who
were simply born and to people who
wanted them and could care for them
or who chose them
i wish i could tell you i found a safe
foster care placement but i never did i
had wonderful social workers who were
very kind and professional and they did
their best in impossible circumstances
and for that i am forever grateful
placement i had was not safe and i went
from one nightmare to another and i had
to play a lot of insane games to have a
safe place to live and i was never
really safe but i had a door that i
could barricade at night and that was as
good as it was going to get
at age 13 i saw that my whole life was
precarious so i signed up to attend
vocational high school and learn to
trade so i can start taking care of
myself as soon as possible i am still in
awe of how practical that was for a 13
year old to do
rents were very high labor laws
prevented me from working enough hours
running machines that i had already
learned how to operate at school to pay
the rent so that plan never worked out
for me
the state i then lived in protected me
so much on one facet of life and not at
all on another more important one of
helping me find a safe place to live
to say i felt thrown away is an
understatement
it gets worse if i had gone to live on
the streets or under a bridge and i did
have a bridge i was considering i would
have been at very high risk for being
trafficked sexually
looking back there were people that
tried that scam on me
and i told them to do anatomically
impossible things to themselves
a 2014 department of justice report
estimated that 85 percent of girls
involved in sex trafficking were
previously involved in the child welfare
system
eighty-five percent
the other terrible outcomes are measured
in huge drawdown dropping
dropping percentages
half of former foster youth are involved
in the criminal justice system about
that same percentage graduate from high
school that number increases to 75
percent will not graduate from high
school if they age out of the foster
care system age out means that they stay
in the foster care system until age 18
or when their state services end
former foster youth are seven times more
likely to experience drug dependency
fifty percent of homeless people have
spent time in foster care only between
three and ten percent of former foster
youth ever graduate from college i got
my degree in 2014.
i don't know what the suicide rates are
for former foster youth but i think that
they are hard to determine with so many
other factors like drug dependency and
the abuse and neglect that first brings
them into the system
i still get very sad when i think of
parts of my childhood and the sadness
can be life-threatening for people and i
will be brutally honest with you here
i consider it like a sort of cancer that
i might i must fight on an ongoing basis
i have people in my life who love me and
they tell me i'm special i found one of
my old social workers he runs a home for
at-risk teens in this state
and he told me that i was his success
story now i refuse to believe that
and i reject that
and i reject that i'm special and i
reject that because i will not be his
only success story
i want other kids in foster care today
to know that they are going to do this
too and that they will be okay and that
they will be success stories and they
will grow up to have people who see them
for who they are and the value they
bring to the world i have a right to
exist
i have paid taxes for many decades and i
have far surpassed what was spent on me
i didn't abuse other people i didn't
commit any crimes i didn't do anything
horrible in my life my friends who also
spent time in foster care are amazing
wonderful people too
i worked a job making some of the
world's most beautiful musical
instruments and i raised two wonderful
children who are also valuable
contributing members to society but even
if i didn't do those things i still have
a right to exist and i have a right to
life
there has been a recent reignition of a
debate that i feel i should say
something about as it pertains to this
issue
the conditions that bring children into
foster care cannot be solved by abortion
because if they could have been foster
care would have gone away in 1973 please
don't assume that we are only
experiencing the muted the member will
suspend for what reason does the member
rise
thank you may continue thank you
please don't assume we are only
experiencing the muted effects of social
problems that would have been worsened
by fewer abortions i believe it's
respect and value
for individual lives that are the
foundation for how we overcome the
problems that lead to child neglect
child abuse and substance abuse that
brings so many children into the foster
care system in the first place
i've had otherwise well-meaning people
tell me i should never have been born
because of the struggles i endured right
in front of me they argue that if it
seems like a child may one day be in
foster care that the child should be
aborted instead and society will be
better for it
can you imagine saying such things to
someone struggling because of their race
or ethnic background or a developmental
delay or other unchangeable factor of
who they are
what if they belong to a group that
tends to have a higher than average
incarceration rates
than other groups do we ever argue that
they should never never have been born
at all
no
because we rightly grant them a higher
level of respect than to ever say that
they should not have been born for those
reasons
i ask that we please grant the same
kindness and respect to future possible
foster youth as well so instead of
saying the world would be better off
without them let's work together to more
explicitly appreciate their inherent
humanity
and value them and make the world a
better place for all of them in ways
that and all the ways that we can thank
you so much for your time and for
listening to the end
[Applause]
one reason member rise
to make a motion stage of motion i i
move that the remarks of the previous
speaker be put into the permanent
journal without objection
without objection
the chair recognizes representative
lebranch for a nanometer's consent
just so everybody knows the member
is going to be doing part of his
unanimous consent in french
and the clerk has advised me that that
is all right i think maybe you'll
realize why
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i rise today
to highlight quebec national day
also known as saint john by this day
as i myself am the son
of immigrants from quebec and am a proud
quebecer
i would like to educate this house about
the long and unique history of the
people of quebec
i will begin by giving the version of in
french and then i will give the english
version
fight
set fight nepal's in fight national
quebec
quebecois
new
it is actor eddie charter it is
intellectual
our totality
person
is
accusing
him
um
[Music]
the member will suspend for a minute
the member has a right to do his
unanimous consent and it's getting awful
loud in here
so if you need to have a conversation
take it out to the ending room
i'm also almost done with the french
part and then we get to the interesting
english version
[Music]
is
we
government canada quebec
or georgie
grandma
said
quebec canada
canada
labor
[Music]
[Applause]
now for the english version
sorry about that
mr speaker
as i said before i rise to highlight
quebec national day
although it takes place on june 24th
this is our last session before this
important holiday
quebecers form one of the biggest
linguistic ethnic and cultural groups
here in the state of new hampshire
yet we are one of the most
underrepresented groups
out of the 400 of us here i am the only
quebecer here that i know of at least
that is why i felt that it is important
for me to highlight this important
holiday
this holiday isn't significant just to
quebec in the future independent nation
of quebec
but for quebecers around the world
in which we celebrate our unique culture
in history
our fourth of july you could say
the people
of quebec have a unique history marked
of oppression by great britain and the
anglophones
this history as we know started in 1763
when great britain conquered new france
since then the anglophones have always
dominated the people of quebec
the anglophones controlled the economy
in all managerial and leadership
positions and enterprises
and treated their french-speaking
employees as second-class citizens
the anglophones never wanted to let
quebecers have self-determination
and control their own destiny
a perfect example of this is the october
crisis of 1970
when the canadian fellow federal
government of prime minister pierre
elliot trudeau
used the war measures act
to declare martial law in quebec and to
occupy the territory of quebec
through force
the federal government used this power
to arrest and detain without warrant or
any charges
journalists activists actors singers and
intellectuals who supported the movement
for independence of quebec
in total
497 people were arrested
many of them for weeks and even months
without cause and over three thousand
warrantless searches and seizures of
homes occurred
even after the october crisis and the
rescinding of the war powers act
the federal government continued to
illegally spy on pro-independence
activists
a few a few years later in 1995 quebec
voted on a referendum from india for
independence from canada
the final result
50.58 percent against and 49.42
opposed
with a total difference of around only
54 000 votes changing history forever
sadly though the federal government
illegally interfered in this referendum
as well
first they illegally funded the no side
of the referendum to a sum of four
million dollars against both quebec and
federal law
secondly months leading up to the
referendum the federal government sent
immigration judges from across the
country to quebec
to accelerate the naturalization process
and give many the right to vote in that
referendum
in total 43 000 individuals received
citizenship in the months prior to the
referendum with a quarter occurring in
the month of the referendum itself
most quebecers actually voted for
independence
when i say that i mean the true
french-speaking and ethnic quebecers
with sixty percent voting in favor of
independence
that is why i always say without the
interference of the canadian federal
government
quebec would be a country today
there are not many members of this house
that know this dark history of quebec in
canada
and how quebec and how canada is not
really a free or democratic country but
it's really an oppressor to my quebecois
people
that is why i decided to speak here
today and to educate my colleagues and
to highlight this holiday of the
quebecois people
happy saint jean baptist day
happy quebec national day
long live a free quebec
long live in independent quebec and
thank you mr speaker
chair recognize the representative walt
for unanimous consent
thank you mr speaker
this is my last session day except for
veto day
and i had a whole list of things that i
wanted to talk about
i guess the most important thing is that
i was here under speaker tucker in 1984
85 brother
it's been a long haul
i've made a lot of friends
and i wanted to take this opportunity to
say goodbye to everyone
everyone who can hear me anyhow
and i want to dispel a rumor
i'm not running off to florida with
laura
[Music]
[Applause]
she's running off with me
during the early days up here
things were quite different
both parties appeared to get along
somewhat
although i do remember a day when all
the democrats walked out
and we just kept on churning out bills
that was a fun time
but my my friends are in both parties
and i would highly recommend that the
folks who are here for their first terms
take heed
every term you spend up here
you make friends
i've made
hundreds of friends up here
and have a friend in every part of the
state
it's best to get along
during the
last
i came back to the house right after my
wife passed away
and it was my friendships
that saved me
if i hadn't been
excuse me if i hadn't been
in
in the house
at the time i probably
wouldn't be here today
and i mean that sincerely
the people that i worked with
their staff
and my colleagues
made it easy for me
so i just wanted to say goodbye to
everyone
and hopefully all you folks who are
going to come on to be reelected
i hope you have the opportunity
to make friends
and
just get along anyhow goodbye
[Applause]
this go ahead
for reasoning member rising
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i'd
move that the remarks that my good
friend from kingston be placed in the
permanent journal without objection
thank you mr speaker chair recognizes
representative shortlife and graham
free inanimate consent
thank you
thank you mr speaker mr speaker we rise
for a more solemn occasion
in that this monday is memorial
day memorial day
has a long tradition across our country
and across this state especially
many of you
as i look around the room have worn the
uniform of our
our nation's armed forces
and i thank you for that service but
each and every one of us
lost friends
relatives
neighbors
ancestors
to protect the freedoms so that i and a
democrat can stand here
and
commemorate their service their
sacrifice
and the fact that there have been
literally thousands
of granite staters who have given their
life
in the protection of life liberty
pursuit of happiness
and to protect our liberties
here at home and abroad and even as we
speak
members of our own national guard are
again deployed and being prepared to
deploy again
across this
world
so it is
imperative that we remember
and this monday at 11 a.m
the governor of our state and i'm sure
that many of us will be at our
beautiful cemetery in bosquen to
commemorate their service their
sacrifice and i hope that i see many of
you
at that ceremony and if not at least
participate in your town's memorials
because without them
none of us would be here
in this chamber
doing what we do
even if we don't always agree on what
the right thing to do is
steve
i didn't know i was going to speak today
and i'm glad my friend
from bedford asked me to join him up
here
all i can say is someone who has seen
american blood shutting shed on foreign
soils in defense of our liberties here
at home
i hope we'll all pause on memorial day
to say thank them for the service they
rendered to our country
and because of their sacrifice we are
all here today enjoying the democracy
that we live in thank you and
thank you john great thank you
mr speaker i would request a moment of
silence for all of those who have given
their life in the defense of our country
thank you mr speaker
what reason remember rise take a guess
mr speaker
put the print the remarks in the uh
journal without objection without
objection
recognize the clerk for a message
mr speaker the senate has voted to lay
on the table the following titled bill
sent up from the house 1476 relative to
release of a defendant pending trial
the chair recognizes representative
major podi for unanimous consent
hey
namaste
thank you mr speaker
i rise before you today
to
talk about
few
may is
may is asian-american pacific heritage
month may is also a better speech and
hearing month
may is also a mental health month
so all three are near and dear to my
heart but i will only focus
today on may is
aapi
the history of an asian
american and pacific
american heritage month
and i proudly stand here as a
asian american
serving my fifth term the member will
suspend for a minute
it's getting awful loud in here we're
getting close to lunch the member has a
right to
speak so please if you if you want to
have a conversation take it out into the
annie room member may continue
thank you mr speaker
asian and pacific american heritage
month was the idea of former
congressional staffer
jeannie jew
who first approached representative
frank horton
about the idea of designating a month to
recognize asian pacific americans
following the united states bicentennial
celebration in 1976.
in june
1977 horton and representative norman y
mineta introduced a resolution in
u.s house of representatives to proclaim
the first 10 days of may as asian
pacific heritage week
a month later a similar bill was
introduced in the senate by former u.s
senator
daniel inouye and spark
mata
matasunaga
president jimmy carter signed a joint
resolution for the celebration of
october 5 5th 1978
in 1990 george h.w bush signed a bill
passed by congress to extend
asian-american heritage week to a month
on may 14 1991
a public law was passed unanimously
by congress and then signed by bush
proclaiming may 1991
and may
1992 as asian and pacific american
heritage month
by 1992
may was officially designated as asian
pacific american heritage month
the month of may was chosen because it
commemorates the migration of the first
immigrants from japan to united states
on may 7 1843
and to celebrate the completion of
transcontinental railroad by over 200
asian immigrants on may 10
however the first asian immigrants
arrived in the u.s
in
1587 when filipinos
first began migrating to california
immigrants continued to come
from the asian continent
and the pacific island through 1920
when the first
samoans were documented in hawaii
and my journey as a
indian american
started in
1985 i arrived in boston
on
april 3rd 1985
and
little did i know that i would be
staying further on
and serving
making this my adopted home and raising
my family and now a grandchild in this
state
and more recently
y2k many of you recognize or remember
that
during y2k there was a huge
migration of
indian americans indians coming to help
with the transition of the computer
breakdown that was going to happen
and new hampshire saw a huge influx of
indians coming
during
just before the y2k
and i was here before that
and
i have made this home
new hampshire my home
for over 30 years
and
also
know that
service to my community
comes from my heart where it comes i
come from the largest democracy
youngest but largest democracy in the
world
to the oldest democracy
and that's my
humble
unanimous consent
namaste
[Applause]
[Music]
we've got
two announcements
and then we're going to take a lunch
chair recognize
what reason memorize
thank you mr speaker move that the
remarks from the previous speaker be
placed in the permanent journal without
the objection chair recognizes
representative osborne
thank you mr speaker republican caucus
in deference to our friends across the
aisle for their win at the great
softball match this past weekend please
allow them to get their ice cream first
and if you could hang here in the
chamber for just a few minutes for we
asked the caucus thank you very much
chair recognizes the representative long
thank you mr speaker the hillsborough
county delegation will be meeting after
that caucus uh if we could meet in
sections five and four
uh right after the republican caucus
thank you
we're going to be at lunch until 5 15.
pat
1 15.
[Music]
all right
could all
members accept the republicans please
leave leave the chamber
[Music]
members
chair recognizes a clerk to reach three
senate messages mr speaker the senate
has adopted the recommendation of the
committee of conference on the following
entitled bills house bill 1431
establishing the parental bill of rights
house bill 1567 relative to consequences
resulting from election official
misconduct
in house bill 1661
relative to regional career technical
education agreements an appropriation
for preliminary work for a new
legislative parking garage health and
human services establishing an
extraordinary need grant for schools the
release of a defendant pending trial
training and procedures for zoning and
planning boards and financial
investments and incentives for
affordable housing development
do you recognize the clerk for a senate
message
mr speaker
house bill 1431 establishing the
parental bill of rights
representative osborne moves the bill
ought to pass
for what reason does the member rise
thank you mr speaker i move to table
house bill 1431
house will be in order
that is a proper motion the motion
before us is the table house bill 1431.
roll call
roll call has has been requested
president blazik that is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote
the motion before us is a table house
bill 1431 members will be in their seats
is the table house bill 1431. this is a
roll call vote
chair recognizes representative allard
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that everyone in
this chamber
desires the very best for the children
of our state
and mr speaker if i know that the
attorney general and the speaker's
chosen counsel do not agree on the
intentions of this bill
and mr speaker if i know that hb 1431
still needs a lot of work to make it the
very best legislation
for families schools and our most
vulnerable students
would i now press the green button and
support the tabling motion
so that we can improve this bill in the
coming session
house will be in order
chair recognizes representative osborne
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that we
have all been waiting all day and
for this
debate to occur and i do know that
house and senate councils have both
weighed in on the
questions that the attorney general has
brought forward and that we will hear
about that during the debate if we are
allowed to have it would i now press the
red button to not table
hb 1431.
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1431.
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press a red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
it is
so
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will attend a state of the vote
169 vote again 100 house will be in
order 173 voting a the tabling motion
fails
chair recognizes representative abramson
sorry about that
thank you mr speaker i guess i really
wore the wrong color today mr speaker i
rise in support
of the committee of conference
recommendation on house bill 1431.
the republican platform simply says on
education to promote education freedom
and parental rights to control the
education of their children
but the republican party is not the only
one that says that so does the
constitution party so does the
uh reform party in the green party and
almost all the independent political
parties and political movements in
groups that are formed out of grassroots
ordinary people around the country they
have all supported
parental rights
and to very extense parental
notification this bill in my opinion is
simply a parental notification that if
something is going on in the schools if
the child is has had a uh confidential
admission with with with other students
and if there's any official activity
involving the school district and its
employees that they that
the parents simply be notified
so i absolutely not only support this
bill i think that that this is one of
the most important sorry this is one of
the most important bills that we take on
this session i've said for years to my
constituents when i ran that i believe
that parents have the right to raise and
educate their own children that it's not
up to the state to make those decisions
especially very personal very intimate
and decisions about their development
their emotional and sexual development
and it's it's therefore my opinion that
after having read this bill and listen
to both sides and look through the
issues and receive the emails of course
and heard the uh the responses from
members of the other side that i still
believe that parents need to be the ones
who are notified by the school
and and make the important decisions
themselves please ignore the color of my
shirt today and press the green button
chair recognize representative blazik
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i would like to begin by
dispelling some of the propaganda
surrounding this bill
critics say that this bill requires
educators to inform parents of a child's
gender identity or expression thus
requiring them to out the child
that is not what the language of this
bill says it says a parent has the right
to be notified when a school employee
initiates investigates or finds the need
for action relating to the school's
policy
regarding the student's gender
expression and identity nowhere in this
bill does it say that if a student
confides in their teacher about their
gender identity that the teacher must
immediately call the parent to divulge
that information
in addition there is nothing in current
law that prevents a teacher from outing
a child to a parent now
the concern i've heard expressed is that
the parent would be told that they
perhaps have a transgender child and
that the child would be endangered
because the parent might abuse them
we cannot presume that all parents are
guilty until proven innocent
if we presume that parents are all
abusive then schools would never inform
the parents of any number of issues with
the child including poor behavior as it
might result in an abusive situation at
home
we have never operated under this
thought process before and we should not
begin now
as this bill is written there are
several ways a school could withhold the
information about the student if there
is evidence that it would endanger the
child
the good supportive parents have every
right to know if there are actions taken
in school that include their children
i equate parental rights to firearm
rights
there are criminals yes
and one of the primary purposes of
government is to punish wrongdoings
but restricting rights from law-abiding
parents and gun owners does not prevent
criminals from participating in criminal
activities
parents are programmed to love and care
for their children like no other adult
and we should be supporting parents so
they can protect their children from
potential bad actors and influences
outside of the home please press the
green button to support this moderate
and common sense legislation
house will be in order
chair recognizes representative roy
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
in my previous life
my job
was to be in charge of investigations
for educator misconduct
as part of that
we learned
that there are certain behaviors
in the field
that needed to be addressed
and part of that was was
how these relationships developed there
are a lot of words to use for it one of
them is grooming
well what if we were here today talking
about
allowing police officers to have secret
relationships
with your child
where
the parent had no right to know what was
going on
and they could talk about sex or
anything gender whatever and you
couldn't find out what that was
i don't think we'd be having this debate
because we would all think it's
ludicrous
as part of my job we looked at trends
and studies
and
teachers are no different than police
officers or state representatives we're
all made up of the same population
there's not a special island somewhere
where we grow police officers or
teachers
they're all just like you and me
and unfortunately among all of us there
are a few bad apples that we have to
watch and protect children from
now if i'm the type of person who has
that affliction that i am attracted to
children what kind of field would i get
into as my career
now
that's the tiny minority
but the tiny minority can do huge damage
there's no doubt that teachers have a
profound effect on the lives of their
students
the student teacher connection can be
positive transforming
opening possibilities for the student
conversely the power imbalance presented
in this influential relationship may be
abused resulting in long-term trauma to
the student this particularly the case
for some sex offenders who use the
profession of teaching to target victims
the case of mary kayla turno captured
national attention when she was
convicted of second-degree child rape
for having sex with a sixth grade
student
miss letourneau who was 35 at the time
pleaded guilty and received a seven and
a half year sentence
lest we think we are immune in new
hampshire
let's all remember the name pamela smart
grooming is a term used to describe the
process by which a sex offender
carefully initiates and maintains
sexually abusive relationships with
children grooming is a conscious
deliberate and carefully orchestrated
approach used by an offender the goal of
grooming is to permit a sexual encounter
and keep it secret
the grooming process encompasses a
variety of methods used by the offender
in addition the method helped maintain
the abusive relationship by encouraging
complicity and secrecy of the victim
here are just a quick few of the things
that we watch out for when we look for
grooming behavior among educators
adults parents any profession when
dealing with children
targeting
they look for vulnerable children
for example those with low self-esteem
low self-confidence
children with less parental oversight
whose parents really aren't involved in
their lives
socially isolated and emotionally needy
children
it sounds awful like like the children
we're trying to protect
by allowing this kind of behavior
caretaking babysitting teaching tutoring
they form special relationships they
become welcome
they give them gifts games special times
they isolate the children from their
family and friends
they seize on feelings of being unloved
and unappreciated not understood
emotional bonding and trust building
desensitizing them to sex talking about
sex
gender
things of this nature
use pretense of teaching and exploring
in closeness
they exploit the victims natural sexual
curiosity
at that age
then they use maintenance bribes gifts
to ensure continued compliance threaten
dire consequences to ensure secrecy
threaten to blame the victim
losing the loss of a loving relationship
these are the exact kind of behaviors
that we discourage and punish and send
people to jail for
yet
opponents of this bill are saying we
should allow
and encourage
we we have to be careful
that when we say that this will be in
order
people that people should be allowed to
have secret relationships with children
how
the house will be in order
if
oh there is a motive it's clearly the
motive is that you say that should not
be able to have the representative the
representative will stop
i didn't hear the complete statement but
i understand you were semi-implying
motive which we don't do
agreed mr speaker i'm not implying
motive i'm saying
that
to say that teachers should be able to
have a secret with a child
that's not a motive that's a fact that's
what you're saying
you may not like it then think about it
at the end of the day
the parents have a right to know
remember the member will suspend
what is your point of order
well in addition to what the previous
member said i think he's not addressing
the bill that this behavior he talks
about is already illegal under existing
law and this is uh
not the main focus of
what's before us so i think he's gone
off topic thank you
i
how how's it been
he is
my my instructions to the member are
not into implied motive and and to talk
about the bill
okay
to be clear i do not think that there is
a motive for
improper relationships
what i am saying is that
this kind of behavior is what allows it
to happen
and we know this
it's been proven time and time again
keeping secrets
with children
that their parents are not allowed to
know about is classically proven
behavior that leads to this type of
thing and we always have to be on guard
for it yes it makes you uncomfortable it
makes me uncomfortable to have to talk
about it but it should not be happening
the parents should always be in the loop
thank you
does the member yield the questions
no member does not yield
chair recognizer representative mullen
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker today i rise in opposition to
house bill 1431
the parents bill of rights which may
seem ironic given the fact that i'm a
parent myself
i believe wholeheartedly in parents
taking responsibility for their
children's education and medical care
i also support school districts and
health care facilities doing everything
they can to engage with parents in
building relationships built on
transparency and trust
but this bill isn't about building
relationships
this bill is about a lack of trust that
robs kids of the opportunity to connect
with caring supportive adults
at the time in their lives when many
need them the most
many of the rights outlined in house
bill 1431 are already law
the right to enroll a child in a public
private or home school the right to
review school records
the right to opt out of certain
topics of instruction the right to
review and object to particular
instructional materials
the right to access state standards
services via an individual educational
plan
the right to enroll in title one or
medicaid services
all of these provisions are already
defined and defended under state and
federal statute
so they are don't appear to be the
rights that a parent would need to fight
for
in addition
there are some rights in this bill
that don't seem right at all
house bill 1431 would require schools to
track and notify parents every time a
student changed their extracurricular
activities or joined a club
like theater
or destination imagination
or the gay straight alliance
schools would be required to report all
discipline imposed by school authorities
without defining either discipline or
school authority
does that mean if chatty seventh grade
susie
needs to have her seat changed that a
call will be made home at the end of the
day
what if active alan throws a tater tot
in the cafeteria is mr vice principal
expected to call mom if he requires al
to clean up the floor around the table
i spent 12 years as a 5th grade teacher
and i can assure you
that dealing with student discipline
is a major portion of every day
what will happen when teachers have 15
phone calls to make at the end of the
day
i can guess that fewer teachers will
report loving their jobs and loving your
job is exactly what makes a great
teacher
and how about the conversations the kids
have with the principal or the assistant
that are meant to redirect or inspire
them our administrators are well loved
by the students
as a teacher i would frequently ask one
of them to intervene who's making that
call
and how long might it be before the
taxpayer is on the hook
for the additional staff that it takes
to clear that daily log jam
the most meaningful professional work i
did was as a school counselor
for 27 years i had the privilege of
assisting students and families during
the most difficult times of their lives
i have held students as they cried over
the loss of a parent
i have held parents who lost children to
illness
to drugs to depression
my door was always open and my office a
refuge for kids and adults who needed a
listening ear
and a compassionate heart to navigate
the challenges that come to all of us
sooner or later
as i stand here today i'm the voice of
every dedicated school counselor
why would you want to silence me
sometimes advocating for a student meant
taking on the school
the teacher really was being mean the
current plan just wasn't working
the student couldn't get their homework
done because nobody at home could help
and if you think i'm kidding try doing
your 7th grade students math homework
and see how well you do
sometimes i needed to address the
parents
he's worried about your drinking
the divorce has her totally distracted
maybe something's interfering with his
learning did either one of you have
trouble in school
sometimes i needed to confront the
student
well
what are you doing if you're not doing
your homework
what did you expect would happen if you
waited until the day before it was due
what made you think that was an opinion
that you should share
like every dedicated school counselor i
based my work on honesty and compassion
why would you want to silence me
during my career i had multiple students
disclosed to me that they had been
sexually abused
another that his mother was being
assaulted
one that a sibling was in trouble with
the law
one that a parent was going to jail and
more than one that they had tried to
take their own life because they didn't
know what else to do
some of these disclosures came
relatively quickly but most of them were
the result of a tested relationship
victimized kids need time
kids with a secret are frequently scared
to death
that speaking the truth will result in
something even more horrifying than the
reality of what they're living
if that school counselor is the
difference between hell or survival
why would you want to silence them
but we already know all of this new
hampshire has been studying adverse
childhood experiences for decades now
we know that the single most protective
factor in building resilient kids is
engaging them in healthy relationships
and we know that schools are an ideal
place to lay the foundation of trust the
kids need to thrive
house bill 1431 requires school
counselors like me to notify parents if
students have a dress code violation
any behavior management or intervention
must also be reported
discussions about gender identity or
expression must be disclosed whether the
student is ready to have that
conversation or not because and i quote
inadvertently
or purposefully withheld information is
subject to disciplinary action
inadvertently
doesn't that mean accidentally or
without intention
in addition
parents may seek monetary damages and
court costs making the desire for
collaboration
and an effort to forge a home school
partnership
seems somewhat antique at best
according to the glad legal advocates
and defenders office one in four lgbtq
youth attempted suicide in 2021
the trevor project reports that 60
percent of lgbtq youth who wanted mental
health care in the past year were unable
to get it
73 percent experienced symptoms of
anxiety and 58 percent suffered from
depression
being
lgbtq is one of the leading causes of
homelessness among teens in america
and that's not because everyone's news
is being greeted with open arms
helping students communicate with their
parents about their sexuality is a good
thing
forcing school personnel to out their
students to parents before anyone is
ready for that open honest and sometimes
tough conversation
is not
we have the opportunity to continue to
help new hampshire students and their
families by opposing this bill
we can deliver the message that living
in new hampshire means that we accept
and value you unconditionally
and that we know
that we are gambling with kids lives
when we don't
please vote no on house bill 1431 by
pushing the red button does the member
yield to questions
house will be in order the member
yielded questions the member does not
yield chair recognizes representative
cofoult
this is the last speaker so will members
take their seats
thank you mr speaker
i rise to speak in support of the
committee of conference report for house
bill
1431.
several years ago a friend and colleague
offered me some vice some advice that
has proven to be very valuable
during my short tenure as a member of
this body
and it was this
when you are engaged in dialogue with
people who do not necessarily agree with
your point of view
it is helpful
to begin with a presumption that
everyone at the table is motivated in
some way
by a positive intention
that has served me well
here it has served me well elsewhere in
my life
and i believe that it would especially
serve us well in the case of house bill
1431.
this bill affirms the primacy
of parents
in raising their children to be happy
healthy productive adults
who can grow up and contribute
positively to society
the bill is five pages long it includes
a number of different provisions
including things like
parents have the right to inspect the
curriculum and know what their kids are
learning in school
it includes parents have a right to see
the child's report card and to know
why they're being promoted to the next
grade or not or why they're being
graduated or not
it reaffirms some of the rights that are
already outlined in statute such as the
right
to exempt your child from certain
immunizations
in the five pages of this bill the term
gender expression is used exactly once
and yet
that has become the pivot point upon
which the passage or failure of this
bill will depend
why is that
we all know someone who has struggled
with their sexual orientation
or their gender identity
in who has suffered emotional pain as a
result
we all know someone who has been
rejected ostracized
ridiculed and bullied
so in keeping with the words of the
chairman of my committee i think that we
ought to to honor the concerns and fears
on both sides of the question
i can't imagine what it is like to
suffer that kind of
difficulty especially as a teenager
i'm sorry that it happens
and i wish i could wave a magic wand and
make it go away
whether this bill passes or fails
will not change that
what this bill will do
is recognize that parents are the
primary agents
in the raising of their children
not junior partners in the process
this would also constitute a very
meaningful step toward restoring trust
in our schools
public schools across the country have
faced a litany of criticism over the
past few years
and much of that criticism although we
ought not to paint with too broad a
brush
much of that criticism
has been deserved
how do we build trust
how do we restore trust
one of the essential elements in the
process of restoring trust
is to extend some measure of trust to
another
the fundamental question that we answer
when we vote yes or no on this bill
you intend this or not
is this
do we trust parents
do we believe that the vast majority of
parents love their children
and will do what is best for them
not necessarily that it's easy
not that there isn't some
difficulty and some tough conversations
along the way but do we believe that the
vast majority of parents
love their children enough to support
them
in their journey and do what is right
this bill does not
require a school to take action
simply because a student is questioning
their sexual orientation or gender
identity
it does not
prevent a student from confiding
in a trusted adult at school
and it does not compel an adult to
violate that confidence
what it does require
is that if a student asks to be
addressed by a differently gendered name
or by different pronouns
or to otherwise make a request to be
treated differently
in this in the public context of the
school
or in a way that triggers
the school to act on a related policy
then the parents should be notified
there was an article in this morning's
union leader
highlighting the story of a mother
whose child in the manchester school
system came out as transgender
she was not notified and she has filed
suit
she was quoted in that article as saying
if her not being told what's going on in
their personal life in school things
could take a turn for the worse if we
don't know
this came from somebody who has been
teaching for 25 years
has been teaching for 17 years
in the same school district
do we trust parents
this bill is a necessary and important
step
toward acknowledging the primary
importance of parents
in their children's lives
and i ask my colleagues to vote yes on
approving the committee of conference
report thank you mr speaker does the
member yield to questions
no remember does not yield
roll call has been requested by
representative silber is that sufficient
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members will take their
seats
so
clearer
we just put the question so
no
we're in the voting mode
the motion before us
is the committee conference report on h
b 1431.
this is going to be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative long
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that the issues that were brought
up in the debate was not brought up
during testimony
if i further know that the issues
that this would create within the court
systems within the parents
if i further know that this will not
solve
what
people are looking for
then when i press the
red button thank you
i recognize representative osborne for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
so if i know that parents
not schools
have the primary right and
responsibility
over the upbringing of children
would i now press the green button to
support families
and not systems and secrets
house house will be in order
the motion before us is the conf
committee conference reporter in h b
1431.
it's a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button of your
polls you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
representative testerman
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
stay to the vote
171 voting yay 176 voting a
house will be in order
[Applause]
the motion fails
for what reason is a member rise to make
a motion state your motion emotion that
i'd like to reconsider the vote and a
motion to reconsider and having voted in
the prevailing side would ask you vote
no
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
on the motion to reconsider
[Music]
so
the motion before us is reconsideration
on house bill 1431
chair recognizes
senator mispedia for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the attorney general's
office testified that the final language
would put the safety of kids at risk
would i now vote
no and push the red button on
reconsideration thank you
the motion before us is the
reconsideration vote on house bill 1431.
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
ground
while members president opportunity vote
also attend the state of the vote
170 voting yeah 177 voting a the motion
to reconsider fails
the chair recognizes the clerk for a
further senate message the house will be
in order
mr speaker house bill 1567 relative to
consequences resulting from election
official misconduct
senator barbara griffin moves we adopt
the committee confidence report
jail recognizes representative bergeron
thank you mr speaker
i rise to speak in opposition to the
committee conference report on house
bill 1567.
the bill is originally amended by the
house proposed fining a municipality if
an election official negligently
failed to perform his duties
the minority of the committee opposed
the amendment because we were concerned
about a lack of due process
the committee of conference report
however did address that concern
it now provides that
communities would have an opportunity to
respond
upon receipt of the attorney general's
notice
of intent to seek a civil penalty as to
why the penalty should not be imposed
and if that was the only change that was
made to the bill i wouldn't be standing
here in opposition to the report
but the committee conference added
language which should concern anyone who
works at the polling place on election
day
the proposed amendment provides that any
election official
who knowingly fails to perform his
duties
will lose his right to vote
it's all getting awful noisy in here the
member has a right to speak
thank you mr speaker
the bill does not give the election
official 45 days to explain why he
should not be prosecuted he doesn't have
the same
opportunities that the municipality has
there are several legal terms that are
used to describe the mental state of a
person who allegedly commits a crime
words like intentionally knowingly
willfully recklessly
or negligent negligently all have
different meanings
the constitution provides that a person
may lose his right to vote if he
willfully
violates the election laws of this state
by definition an act is done willfully
if done voluntarily and intentionally
and with a specific intent to do
something the law forbids
this report proposes taking away a
person's right to vote if he knowingly
fails to perform an election duty
knowingly with respect to conduct means
that a person has actual knowledge or
should have known
of the conduct or the circumstances
i know that there are a number of
members of this chamber who have served
as election officials
as supervisors of the checklist
selectmen moderators ballot clerks
and i wonder how many of them on their
first day of working at the polls knew
all the laws that are contained in the
400 page election law book and the 400
page election procedure manual and the
content of all the memoranda and
opinions
that are distributed by the secretary of
state in the eternal attorney general's
office during an election cycle
but under this bill
they should know all that material
because if they make a mistake have an
accident or have some other innocent
reason for not handling election
procedures a hundred percent accurately
they could lose their right to vote
secretary of state does provide some
training to election officials every two
years
but that those training sessions are
mostly overviews and summaries of
changes in election law and procedures
they don't get into every nitty gritty
detail of what a supervisor the
checklist needs to do what a selectmen
needs to do what a moderator needs to do
or what a ballot clerk needs to do
their attorney general's office recruits
and then sends representatives out
during state elections to examine the
polling places see how they're set up
and provides them with checklists and
worksheets to evaluate what's being done
at the polling places
but many of these people have less
training and experience than the
election officials at the polls
and frankly they make mistakes
as an example a number of years ago one
representative of the attorney general's
office came to a polling place in nashua
and on that checklist they wrote that
there was no american flag outside of
the polling place
we got a report in nashua that
complained about that violation from the
attorney general's office well the fact
is
there was a flag outside the polling
place all the polling places are held in
schools in nashua all the schools have
flag poles near the entrance and all the
flag poles had flags on them someone
made a mistake
but that checklist under this law could
have been used by the attorney general
as sufficient documentation to try and
take someone's right to vote away
i spent 16 years as a city clerk in
nashua running elections and five years
before that in the city of manchester as
deputy clerk running elections
i never had anyone of the hundreds of
election officials that i worked with
the state's election laws
but i can assure you that not all of
them came into their positions knowing
everything that they needed to know to
perform their duties
and that some of those people may have
inadvertently made some mistakes
we don't need a law that's going to take
their right or vote away because they
made a mistake
the proposed amendment is bad
legislation the language in the bill is
inconsistent with terminology in the
constitution
less due process has afforded
individuals than is provided for
municipalities
many municipalities are already
experiencing difficulty in recruiting
sufficient numbers of volunteer election
officials to staff their polling places
and the threats of additional potential
litigation of those officials
due to a mistake or accident or some
other innocent reason is unnecessary and
counterproductive
i would therefore ask that you vote
against this report by pressing the red
no button thank you
geo recognizer
representative barbara griffin
thank you mr speaker
this bill is an attempt to provide
remedies in regards to misconduct at
polling places by election officials let
me first address the last points raised
by the previous speaker from nashua
the reality is the law as you heard and
the constitution
all already provides that upon a
criminal conviction
an
election official can lose their right
to vote as can someone convicted of
violation of election law we've all
heard of people voting twice in
elections they lose their right to vote
this is not a new provision
and it's not inconsistent
this was the provision that the senate
when it received the bill from the house
placed in the bill and
replaced what we had done with the house
so the conferees
accepted what had been done by the
senate
and then
added and were able to merge the two
with what we had done in this body in
the house
and this bill is somewhat of an example
of something that i think we can all
agree we run into when we propose a bill
there are certain things that when we
propose them in a bill we know we are
going to get objection to them
one of them is when we have a bill that
proposes officials of any kind or any
person do more work
right in addition to taking
these three data points we now want you
to take five
we know that in our personal life when
we have staff and we ask them to do more
they don't want to do it
so this bill has a little bit of that in
it so people didn't like it
we also know as the body that we hear
all the time when there's anything in a
bill in regards to penalties
criminal penalties or civil penalties
there's going to be significant pushback
and when it involves fines
there's even more pushback
but at a certain point there needs to be
some ability
for accountability
and in regards to the elections that
have been conducted we know now just in
the elections in 2020
that the communities of bedford laconia
and windham
had substantial problems with the
conduct of their elections
due to
the performance of people at the polls
and some of that performance
was in violation of law
and contrary to what was sworn to under
oath
by some of the workers at the ballot law
commission
and no one was held accountable
and the state
bears the expense of the attorney
general's investigation in windham it
was an 11-page letter bedford laconia
further letters
other communities further letters
every election there is a stack of
letters generated in regards to
allegations that things are not done
properly at the polls
at a certain point we need to say to the
persons casting the ballots there will
be accountability for making sure that
job is done right
and that's what 1567 seeks to do
in a conversation with the enforcing
agency of our election laws attorney
general's the question was made why
isn't there i made the question why
isn't there anything ever done about
this i have an 11-page letter why isn't
anything being done
because the reality of getting a
criminal conviction
is that it is very hard to do
no one wants to find people criminally
liable
if they didn't understand what they were
doing but at a certain point people in
our community need to be responsible for
making sure jobs are done correctly as a
former member of the board of selectmen
i was required to be at the polls all
day
my signature went on the tape on the box
i there was some responsibility given to
me by the voters of goffstown to ensure
that the election was done properly
and what we are finding is is that in
municipalities there is simply no one
stepping to the plate to take
responsibility
so how do we get them to do that well
unfortunately the answer is
you suggest that they might be fined
you give the attorney general's office
the ability to seek penalties that does
not require a criminal conviction
because they are reluctant to begin that
process for the time expense and
likelihood the most important thing
is to make sure our elections are
conducted properly and all legal ballots
are counted properly
and we get there by making sure the
people that are there are doing their
job i have no dispute with the
representative from nashua who i i hold
great admiration for in his at in his
administration of our election laws and
and knowledge of them but what i'm
talking about is the administration of
laws and the people who are working
there and if you are choosing to be a
part of this process
i am simply asking them in this bill
on behalf of my constituents to pay
attention
to make sure it's done right
and maybe next time when a community
gets a letter that's 11 pages long
in regards to what was done wrong
they won't simply say
oh well
you want to come and monitor our next
election fine
maybe next time the community will do
something this bill is not about
collecting fines or penalties or taking
away anybody's right to vote
it's about communicating that we all
have a responsibility in our elections
and we need to give everyone the tools
to know what they're supposed to do and
to be able to enforce them
thank you does the member yield to
questions
no i do not thank you remember does not
yield
the motion before us is the committee
conference report h on hb 1567.
a roll call has been requested by
representative o'brien is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
members take your seats
the motion before us is the committee of
conference reporter in hb 1567
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
bergeron for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know the terms used in the proposed
law are in conflict conflict with
terminology in the state constitution
and if i know that many of the people
recruited by the attorney general's
office to conduct polling site
inspections on election day have less
training and experience than the
election officials working at the polls
and if i know that his existing law
provides that someone who knowingly
fails to perform his duties is guilty of
a misdemeanor and that our state
constitution provides that someone who
willfully violates the election laws of
the state can lose his right to vote and
that therefore this proposed law is
unnecessary would i then press the red
no button to reject the committee of
conference report thank you
chair i recognize representative barbara
griffin for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that our election officials do
great work and the best that they can
and that they deserve the support and
attention of our communities
and their boards of selectmen and town
councils and aldermen
and if i know that there are repeated
instances unfortunately of communities
where ballots are not being properly
handled and the ability to do follow-up
and attention to those issues has been
limited based on the
constraints
for the attorney general and what can be
done in current statute
and if i know that the current
provisions in statute relate only to
criminal conduct with the ag has
informed us is difficult to prove and
leaves no recourse for certain civil
errors
and that those investigations or costs
that the entire state bears both in
finances and in the integrity of our
elections would i now press the green
button to support the conferees thank
you
motion before his committee conference
report on hb 1567 it's a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button for these stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
joseph
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
under an 84 voting a 161 voting a
committee report is adopted
and i recognize the clerk for a report
mr speaker the committee on enrolled
bills is it has examining found
correctly enrolled the following
entitled senate bills senate bill 200
abortion in congressional districts
for what reason does a member rise
mr speaker i move that the debate be
placed in the permanent journal on hb
1431.
the question has been objected so the
motion before us is to put the debate on
to print the remarks of 1431.
this will be a division vote members
take your seats
the motion before us is to print the
remarks of the previous debate in a
permanent journal
got it
again the motion before us is to print
the remarks on the debate on 1431 in the
permanent journal this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
thank you mr speaker
this committee report is a
monster of a bill with 79 sections
i'll highlight a couple for you
section 78 and 79 of this bill
deal with financial investments and
incentives
for affordable housing development by
municipalities
what this bill attempts to do is change
the definition of public use
to encourage local municipalities to buy
land for housing or actually get in the
business of building apartments that's a
terrible idea
why on earth would think government is
the answer to the housing problem
government causes the problem in many
instances through onerous zoning
regulations unreasonable wetlands
restrictions expensive fire sprinklers a
lengthy approval and permitting process
and myriad more intrusions on the
marketplace that lead to the shortage of
inventory we have
workforce housing is a misnomer it's
just housing if high-end luxury
apartments are built
higher income tenants will move to the
move out of the old drafty noisy
buildings into the nice fancy new ones
thereby providing more available and
affordable housing in the vacating units
it's simple supply and demand
the market needs more supply right now
so what we need to do is get state and
town bureaucracies and regulations out
of the way that is the solution not
giving more money and powers to
government
by giving towns the authoritarian
ability to acquire land for or build
housing
you're not only spitting in the faces of
private sector developers and investors
who already took the risks raised
capital and jumped through all the hoops
but didn't get subsidies
but you're also perverting the idea of
public use
that is meant for things like utilities
roads parks and recreational areas
town buildings and schools
when local governments become developers
it invariably leads to even more
cronyism
insider trading corporate greed and
graft
without market risks and pricing signals
government projects always cost more
than projected and take longer than
promised and the taxpayers are the
victims
nobody in this body should endorse more
public housing product projects which is
what we're going to get with this
ill-conceived legislation
another section of the proposed
legislation has to do with lead hazards
in residential units
this bill drastically lowers the
threshold by which dhhs can swoop in and
force a landlord or property owner to a
bait lead in a residential unit
regardless of where the child contracted
or ate or ingested the lead
the actual source could be at school or
in daycare or grandma's house or eating
toys
nothing to do with the living unit
the problem here is that the property
owner could be forced to spend tens of
thousands of dollars on abatement even
when the housing unit isn't the cause
abatement orders are a gigantic expense
for property owners ultimately leading
to higher rents and less affordable
housing if that's what you want that's
what you're going to get with this bill
nobody is arguing that lead poisoning
isn't a very serious problem
we all know that but this
one-size-fits-all legislation is not the
answer
it's more feel-good legislation that
will cause more problems than it fixes
for these reasons i'm a big red button
no on this bill and i hope the
independent thinkers in this body will
join me
thank you mr speaker
i recognize representative
thank you
mr speaker
welcome
to washington d.c
mr speaker
house bill 1661 has had 16 and now i
heard it only has 10
other major bills included
we've always voted against these ominous
bills
if i can say the word right
so let me get house will be in order
thank you mr speaker
so let me get down to the crutch that i
have here
is the parking garage
9.35 million dollars is going to go to
that parking garage
let me explain some of it
and you tell me if this sounds right
design and engineer of a 450 space
parking garage is going to be 1.4
million dollars
not one brick is going to be laid
but 1.4 million just to draw it on a
piece of paper
design and engineer cost to demolish
store street garage is 1.5
uh 105 000
just to draw it on a piece of paper how
they're going to tear the thing down a
hundred and five thousand dollars
and then thirty five thousand dollars is
going to go to demolish just to draw on
a piece of paper demolish the dog ga
building over there
um
25 000 i don't understand this one to
abandon capital street so i'm assuming
they're going to close a street but it
costs 25 000 to put up
a couple do not enter signs
that sounds like a lot of money
so now here comes the good part
for somebody
cost of demolition of the bill doj
building is going to be 1.1 million
dollars cost an engineer
of the doj prep site is 535 000
just to level the dirt out once the
building's gone probably throw a little
grass seed down
535 dollars
now this is one that really gets me and
i'm going to help here
cost to move the department of justice
i guess down by where the j or the
prison is
1.2 million dollars
mr speaker i'll tell you right now i'll
go rent a u-haul and i'll do it for that
because that's a lot of money to move
some desk
approximate cost
for a 50 000 square foot because i heard
the building they're going to
the ag is going to is huge so they're
going to have 50 000 square feet of it
renovated
to accommodate
the ag at a cost of 3.7 million dollars
and then
to lease the building
is going to be 1.2 million dollars a
year
a hundred thousand dollars a month i'm
wondering whose friend is getting rich
on this deal
so representative
that was out of line
well somebody is going to get rich
the member will
conduct himself properly before making
accusations that have no merit all right
thank you mr speaker
i was thinking the same thing myself
so mr speaker
so lastly mr speaker
what message is this send in
with gas heading to six dollars a gallon
someone has to stand up and represent
the hard-working families and seniors of
new hampshire mr speaker that's going to
be me right here with my no vote
we at this time mr speaker do not need a
35 million dollar parking garage so
representatives can save a two block
walk that's right mr speaker this 35
million dollar legislative parking
garage with fancy granite faced pillars
will save us about two blocks of walk-in
mr speaker i am speaking strictly for
myself i need those two blocks
if we have all this extra money kicking
around mr speaker we should
give every residential homeowner a four
or five hundred dollar gift card instead
of spending 9.3 million dollars to prep
and design this
450 car parking garage before even one
brick is laid
and not and that's not even included in
the tens of millions and mr speaker i
mean tens of millions of dollars that
was added into this
uh pet project that we added into house
bill 1661.
just like washington dc does to us
and we complain rightfully every time
lastly mr speaker
when it comes to this washington dc
style pork
that was added into this new hampshire
35 million dollar parking garage i only
have a few words
taxation is theft
does a member yield to questions
remember does not yield
chair recognized representative sylvia
thank you mr speaker
let me start off with apologizing for
confusing my entitlement programs
there's so many that it's really hard to
keep track of but
i i know that when my my tax my paycheck
came through it had this fica on it and
i was like confused as to what it was
and
it didn't say medicare medicaid social
security and all that
so
on to this bills
we have
a problem with
housing
there aren't enough
rental units
there's a tremendous problem and we're
going to make it worse with this and yes
i'm speaking about the
lead paint poisoning prevention and
control
this has to do with the investigation
what this section 29 does
is
it strikes a part where two tests are
required
so currently as i understand it
first test
would signal that there's a problem
and
investigation would be done to try and
track down the source as opposed to what
is going to happen is the assumption
will be that the
apartment needs to be abated
so
there are many different
causes
of increased lead levels in children and
perhaps i i messed up on the the
medicare medicaid thing because i grew
up before 78 and it was leading the gas
and there was lead in the paint so
[Music]
so
we are going to
cause more trouble
in rental housing we are going to
increase the price of rentals
we are going to drive
some homeowners and some building owners
to convert their units to something
other than rentals it's anything but
affordable
and the workforce housing stuff is not
going to help as we've heard previously
another section of this bill
that concerns me
is section 68 child protection act
confidentiality
this amendment
uh to
rsa 169
dash c colon 25 roman 2
it shall be unlawful
for any person present
present during
a child abuse or neglect hearing to
disclose any information concerning the
hearing that may identify the child or
parent who is involved in the involved
in the hearing
without the prior permission of the
court
any person
who knowingly violates this provision
shall be guilty of
not a misdemeanor anymore
just a violation a slap on the wrist
that doesn't sound very good to me
so
there are no numerous reasons to vote
against this bill and i'll ask for a
roll call
and please press a red button
i recognize representative abramson
thank you mr speaker i rise in
opposition to the committee of
conference report on house bill 1661
relative to the plan building 171 000
per parking space parking garage the
bill would also
do 29 other things under one version of
it
establish a special fund for
administration of opioid treatment
programs
removes references to the anna philbrook
center laconia state school and the
colonial developmental services revival
revises child care license
definitions it repeals certain reporting
requirements
it
removes all sorts of provisions and
other parts of law that are completely
unrelated to what the original bill
was uh written for
the house does not send out omnibus
bills and we never have
one of the added provisions that's that
was included
uh lists certain offenses which if
committed by the defendant create a
rebuttable presumption that the
defendant is a danger of the public and
shall be detained for up to 36 hours
which was opposed by house republican
alliance new hampshire liberty alliance
the new hampshire civil liberties union
americans for prosperity and numerous
public defenders and others the reese
o'keefe law firm warned that quote the
new proposal targets increased
incarceration and cash bail for those
already accused or convicted of various
level crimes who are free even if quote
the court found the accused not
dangerous to themselves or others taking
away discretion from the judge the new
hampshire bolton warned that that
provision of the bill
would disproportionately harm black
granite staters unquote in new york
state where they they did the same thing
they found that only two percent of
those released under bail reform
actually reoffend
the new hampshire constitution requires
that each bill each of these 29 bills
must get its own public hearing and its
own vote on the floor
packing as many as 29 unrelated bills
onto legislation that originally related
to quote
regional career technical education
agreements unquote
takes away the ability of the voters to
see our voting record and hold
legislators accountable for their votes
mr speaker
this bill is the worst idea
and putting it all together as one
gigantic omnibus bill is the worst idea
since congress spent three million
dollars injecting hamsters with steroids
and then watching them fight in a
northwestern university study
i ask members to press the red button
and vote this bill down and we can bring
these 29 issues up again next session
thank you
jail recognized representative ladd
thank you very much mr speaker
this bill hb 1661 came to us
with a number of additions added to that
bill
we started on the thursday and ended up
excuse me we started on a friday in
committee conference
and ended up on thursday minutes before
the deadline
several these components include
regional career technical education
agreements and calendar alignment
which that came out of committee
unanimously here in this house
and through house finance as well
an appropriation for primary preliminary
work dealing with the parking garage
well i'll get into a little later
health and human services
components in sb 430
establishing an extraordinary needs
grant for schools which we've already
addressed in sb 420.
the release of defending
a defendant pending trial
bail reform in h.b 1476 that was in it
and training procedures
and other
aspects of zba's and planning boards in
our communities throughout the state
including affordable housing this all
came to us
and we went through it bit by bit and
i'm going to try to do that right now
with you
the first portion of the bill the
original portion of the bill
is a result of five to six years of hard
work and planning
by those from north to south east to
west in the state to have something to
do with career and technical education
including parents including directors
including advisory councils including
folks like the new hampshire automobile
association all working towards trying
to double the number of kids that we're
going to have graduating from our high
schools here
and preparing them for career
that we urgently need to maintain our
economy in this state
this bill is probably if i were to name
two bills or three bills in education
which are top priority this is one of
them and it's a bipartisan bill 1661.
going on down to the parking garage
i don't park my car there anymore
and even i would i wouldn't
i have seen cement on the floor of that
garage that has come from the ceiling
and there are staff working in this
building have had that occur as well
this bill will provide the 9.35 million
dollars necessary for design
and preparing for engineering and
raising the building and getting us into
a place that's needed that's safe and
will provide up a location to put our
vehicles
we're well beyond the lifespan of that
garage down in store street well beyond
the lifespan and now we're at a point
where such disrepair
there's going to be an accident if we
let it go much longer we cannot kick
this can down the road any further it's
time to do something and that time
is now
when you're looking at the third
component of this bill
the health and human services
there has been a whole lot of discussion
on that
but i will say one thing to all of you
right here
lead in any water is not healthy
especially for children and pregnant
women
looking at this bill there's been some
discussion about the opioid treatment
programs which we will have as a result
of this bill what it does it provides
the commissioner
the authority to collect fees and to
generate
criteria and conditions for
certification permitting and training of
staff in this area
we also have another portion within that
bill which deals with
develop a pilot program provide services
to those developmental disabilities for
children that are still in
public education
ages 18 through 21
but do not have services delivered to
them under the education local education
agency we can now delve into the
disabilities area to provide that
support through this pilot program which
will be working with 20 individuals and
possibly more than that to try and get
this program up and running
kinship care homes we haven't any
discussion on that
we have numerous problems throughout
this entire state now dealing with abuse
of youngsters abuse or neglect that's
occurring
and it's healthy and has to be healthier
to get them into another location
a lot of times
grandparents are looked at are those
which are kin to the child
this bill will provide you don't have to
have licensing to do this
and up to now you can get an exception
for 30 days extends that period of time
to 180 days without having that
licensure as a parent
a grandparent a nephew a niece
this is drastically needed in our
society today
our moral compass has gone askew
and we're seeing it in our schools
we're scansing it in our society
we cannot look the other way
food service licensure exemptions were
made for camps
health and human services will get up
individual over their business
improvement administrator
looking at our critical facilities in
the state hospitals in areas like
glencliff
up where i live up in warren
they take everybody that the others
don't want
every day i drive by that on the way
down here to concord i see signs out
front need nurses need nurses
this provides the support to places like
glencliff to have that support
it provides the ability to have bonuses
to attract them and be competitive with
places like dartmouth
hitchcock or cottage hospital glencliff
needs this support
there's no other place for those those
people in this home
medicaid reimbursement for critical care
hospitals that's in this bill as well
that critical care that support is
needed for our birthing facilities in
these hospitals
alternative treatment centers and on it
goes
this bill has a whole lot more in it
and it's not bad stuff
we did
when we looked at this bill
we remove removed
420 the extraordinary needs grant we've
already dealt with that this morning
that was out of this bill
we took out 1476 bail reform that's out
of this bill
what we did look at was sb 400
and there's been some discussion about
that today
the amended version that you we have
before us today right now
is 60 percent shorter than that that
came at us there was a lot of work done
in the committee a conference
some may like it some may not
but
here are some of the things which we
were removed from that bill
remove the language to automatically
allow towns and cities to construct
workforce housing and economic
development and revitalization districts
amending language provides the towns and
cities may not shall
do so only if provided and approved by
the town legislative body
or in the case of a city the city uh
elected body
so we took out the requirement of shall
and may is there now
is it allows local control we often
times about local control
conferees removed the provision that
would allow towns to extend local tax
breaks for workforce housing
developments that's been removed
conferees removed language that would
have prevented towns from adding age
restrictions to workforce housing that
was removed
the definition in reference to
inclusionary zoning
was struck out
the definition for workforce housing
that meant housing which is intended for
the sale and which is affordable to a
household is
gone
all reference to planning and zoning
rehearing and appealing appeal
procedures and court review have been
eliminated
the new hampshire housing championship
champion certification program is out
this program would have enabled
participating districts
possessing a new hampshire housing
champions certificate to receive
preferential access to state resources
including but not limited to
discretionary state funds infrastructure
funds
all reference to certification advisory
board which would have been authorized
for to review and approve proposed rules
and erect any amendments to this
legislation
are gone
what it did leave in that bill
it left sb 400 including
the requirement local use boards provide
written findings of fact explaining why
certain housing projects are rejected i
chaired us as eba i've chaired a
planning board in the state i know that
it's important that when you make
conclusions in accordance with statute
you have now there be a report made
in accordance with statute that's what
this is asking for
the bill also requires zoning boards of
adjustment to make decisions on
applications within 90 days
of the receiving
application
a statewide training program for local
boards has been kept in the bill however
this training is optional and left again
to local control
a committee at conference is one in
which you have to recognize the good the
bad and the ugly we took the ugly out
and what we want now is to move the
content in this building which is going
to be best for our state
and best for those to live in this state
and i think we've done that so thank you
very much i would hope that we would
push the green button on this bill thank
you
does the member yield to questions yes
number yields main choir
uh thank you so much for taking my
question
it's my understanding that if we do not
move
forward today
providing this 9.4 million
that we will be
without a garage
when store street falls down
which probably
will occur
in the next
10 minutes no
[Laughter]
in the next few years is this correct
i know we all want to go home i'll still
answer yes
for what reason is a member rise uh to
make a motion
state your motion i would like to lay
1661 on the table
it is a proper motion
motion is the table 1661.
division has been requested members will
take their seats
oh
so
we're ready
yes
that's right
i didn't know about it
the motion before us is lay house bill
1661 on the table
this is going to be a division vote
chair recognizes representative contoir
to
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that this omnibus
bill
is a smorgasbord of bills that were
crammed together at the last moment
and mr speaker if i know that all of
these bills can be submitted in just a
mere four months
would i now press
the green button to table this motion
thank you
chair recognizes representative stephen
smith for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that i hate it when concrete
falls on my hood
but you know what i hate worse
if i know that i hate being forced to
pay two million dollars for bondo and
bailing wire to hold that monstrosity on
store street together and we're gonna do
it because it's a safety regulation
mr speaker if i'm tired of putting all
that money into a building that we will
never control that the city wants torn
down then would i vote against the
tabling motion right now
the motion before us is the table health
bill 1661.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you opposed to press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
representative mcgee
president an opportunity vote house will
attend the state of the vote
99 vote today 243 voting a the tabling
motion fails we're back to the original
motion
which is the adopted committee report on
house bill 1661
representative proud has requested a
roll call as that's officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
oh
the motion before us
is
the adoption of the committee report on
house bill 1661
this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative contoir for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you again mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that this omnibus bill is a
smorgasbord of bills that were all
crammed together at the last moment
and mr speaker if i know that the
parking garage was rushed
and this rush nature has an appearance
of impropriety for the house as we will
be the beneficiaries of it
and mr speaker if i know that this bill
takes away local control
and will burden local services and raise
property taxes
and mr speaker
if i know that all of these bills
again can be submitted in a mere four
months
and mr speaker if i know that local
control is the new hampshire way
would i now press the red button
house will be in order chair recognizes
representative stephen smith for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i agree that in four short months
bills can be filed and that pieces of
this that are not time sensitive i can
file a repeal bill and mr speaker if i
also know that what is time sensitive is
the garage because the property is
available now
and there's funding available now
and that if we don't move on it i i
don't know where you're all going to
park in four years that's just how it is
mr speaker if i know that the career
technical education program that this
bill advances is important
to put people back into trades which are
desperately needed now
and if i know that the dhhs portion of
the bill is exactly what you all passed
out of house finance and out of this
chamber earlier then would i press the
green button
the motion before us is adoption the
committee report in house bill
six six one this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you
press the green button every opposed to
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
mall members president an opportunity to
vote household 10 state of the vote
244 voting yay 99 voting a committee
report is adopted
chair recognizes the member from auburn
representative osborne for the motion to
adjourn from the early session are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Applause]
you didn't see
oh
i want to get out of here
representative osborne has to read the
motion
i was jumping the gun a little bit there
you think we would know this routine by
now but it resolved that the house now
adjourned from the early session and the
business of the late session be in order
at the present time
now are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
i suppose they always have an emotion is
adopted
for what reason does a member
rise i'd like to i'd like to make a
motion
state your motion
um i make a motion that the remarks made
by
our colleague representative lebranch on
his unanimous consent be printed in the
permanent journal
without objection
[Music]
we have three requests for unanimous
consent
i recognize representative abramson
really sure
uh thank you mr speaker first i want to
apologize for uh wearing my don baldick
i want to apologize for wearing my don
boldix speaker sticker at the well i
forgot remember the member has a right
to speak so
please if you're going to if you're
going to exit exit quietly
remember it may continue
so 20 years ago i had a conversation
with representative steve allencourt he
was the first legislator i ever
spoke with and had a conversation with
about legislative issues and the issue
that came up with was whether or not to
lower the drinking age in new hampshire
to 18.
and that's a bill that that as he said
comes up every almost every session
but when i came up to the legislature as
a private citizen
several members mentioned the national
minimum drinking age act which is a
federal bill
uh which includes a couple of different
exceptions but there's there's only one
operative sentence in it the whole the
whole law is five sentences long but
i'll just read the one the secretary
shall withhold 10
percent of the amount required to be
apportioned by any state under each of
the sections in 104
of this title
on the first day of each fiscal year
after the second fiscal year beginning
in september 1985 in which the purchase
or sale
sorry the purchase or public possession
in any such state of any alcoholic
beverage by a person who is less than 21
years of age is lawful every time this
feels
every time this bill has come up we hear
the national minimum drinking age act as
that being the reason that we would lose
10 percent of our federal highway
funding but 45 state legislatures
45 state legislatures make exceptions
for religious reasons or family reasons
or others
what what vallencourt told me was that
even if you have to be
abrasive even if you
upset people's opinions even if you
offend people to tell the truth at the
well
and i i've learned over the years in
three terms as a state representative
that your integrity is really all you
have is we're just one of four hundred
members
and if members here do support alcohol
prohibition marijuana prohibition gun
prohibition gambling prohibition or any
other prohibition policy then by all
means say so but don't hide behind
a a federal law that
everyone has to go refer to and go read
to find out
that state legislatures do in fact have
the right to include religious and
family exemptions to the drinking age 45
states have different exceptions and not
a single one has lost a dollar in
federal funding
90 years ago in in the other room
at a state ratifying convention nine
delegates met
to ratify the 21st amendment bringing an
end to alcohol prohibition in our
society
and they meant for only a single purpose
they had a very very short discussion
and like 30 somewhat other states they
finally brought an end to alcohol
prohibition in our society
the member has a right to speak
we're almost done
so please give courtesy to the speakers
so i have only one point to make
in case i don't get reelected for the
next term and this is if this is the
last time you ever hear me
prohibition never works
it always has always made crime worse
whether it was drug prohibition alcohol
prohibition gun prohibition or any other
type it always breaks down respect for
the rule of law it always results in a
loss of civil liberties it always
results in swat rates and mass
incarceration and wasting juries time
and wasting people's time and money it
has always contributed to a breakdown
and respect for the rule of law in any
society every time congress has stepped
up drug prohibition crime has gone up
every time congress stepped up alcohol
prohibition crime went up every time
congress stepped up the
gun prohibition crime has gone up and we
don't have much control over what
congress does as other members have said
but we can at least set an example that
we will be
careful not only with the laws that we
enact
but also with the statements that we
make on the floor you've heard me
apologize a number of times this session
for statements that i made
that uh could be misinterpreted and i
just did so again for my don boldic
sticker but
i'm asking members be truthful be
careful do your research
and
don't claim that a federal law says
something that it doesn't say
do you recognize representative of allah
bringing atoms with consent
thank you mr speaker thank you
colleagues
this also may be my last
time at the well and i thank you for
your indulgence and
it's been an honor to work with you
resilience
resilience is hard
like you
i have an inner flame of hope
a faith in people and a vision of better
tomorrows and this flame
fuels my public service
winds of despair almost extinguished my
flame of hope on tuesday
almost
did somebody withdraw consent
representative harrington withdrew
consent
we're going to put this to a vote shall
remember continue
are you ready
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
whether the member continues
so
hey
members need to be in their seats this
is a roll call vote
the motion before us
is whether
the member can continue
in their speech on unanimous consent
this is going to be a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
first
so
what's up
all members president opportunity vote
house will attend state of the vote
160 voting 818 voting a the member will
continue
thank you
yesterday
the member will suspend for a minute
we need to keep members in the chamber
so we can have
enough of a quorum to finish our
business for today
the member will continue
thank you mr speaker yesterday i was in
a seacoast area high school talking with
the head of counseling
and they told me that that school used
to have nine scheduled fire drills
during the school year and now
they have five fire drills and four
active shooter drills instead
like many of you here i have worked both
in a school and for me it was a seacoast
elementary school where i
um was a paraprofessional in the special
ed department
and i also volunteered as many of you
did as a room parent a coach a scout
leader and an activity chaperone
it was the best
when as an adult though you participate
in one of these active shooter drills it
is really painful to be with the
students as they huddle
against a cement wall away from the
windows and the doors
and as a parent i have felt the panic
and the fear of calling my child's cell
phone to hear their voice when i got
word
that there was a gunman waving a gun
around in the parking lot of the
supermarket they were shopping in
we don't have gun policies in this state
we leave our fate to chance
leaving our fate to chance means that
anything is possible
anything can happen
we roll the dice every day with our
children's safety
our policy on gun violence prevention
is to depend on luck
and i don't think it's a good policy to
depend on luck because luck is
capricious
we are only five months into this year
and 27 american schools have experienced
shootings
last year
there were 34 over the whole school year
and schools were closed for a
significant portion of the year because
of a covid19 pandemic
eight more school shootings this year
and we break the record
but the unlucky
aren't only limited to schools you can
be unlucky shopping for groceries
you can be unlucky praying in a
synagogue or at a church
you can be unlucky playing ball at the
field attending a music festival or
hearing an elected official speak
outside
you can be unlucky at the movies the
possibilities are just endless
particularly in new hampshire in america
on this
147th day of the year
we have experienced
213 mass shootings
no doubt by now everyone has heard the
names of the murdered children teachers
grandparents security guards
it is really important to honor their
memories
may their memories be a blessing
and in just the past 147 days
thousands of emts
firefighters
and law enforcement have rushed
to the bloody crime scenes
unfortunately the continuous pictures
biographies the stories from relatives
and the murder victims have
no impact
on the majority of hearts in this
chamber as we have seen from our voting
so what if today
what if right now
we just acknowledge the survivors
and the responders
the 9-1-1 dispatchers who field the
cause of terror from the terrorized
and send help
we know the haunting sounds of the
voices of the victims in the background
noises of active crimes
can never be unheard thank you
let's acknowledge the firefighters and
the police who race into places
people should be racing out of
securing crime scenes and bearing the
burden of having to try to quickly
discern who is friend or foe during
calamity
is difficult and we thank you
let's think about the emts working to
restart hearts that have stopped
plug
gaping wounds
tighten tourniquets to save limbs
and encourage our loved ones to just
hang on
as they are raced to the hospital
we thank you
the emergency room staff who whisk the
gurneys of the bleeding and broken into
sterile rooms and use all of their
medical education and training to fix
what has been blown apart
the doctors and nurses who work
valiantly to save lives and keep us
updated in waiting rooms where we
suffocate
from worry and despair
thank you
let's remember the custodians who have
to pick up the computers backpacks lunch
boxes overturned shopping carts and
prayer books
so that the crime scene cleaners can
come in and scoop up mounds of flesh and
wipe blood stains off the walls and the
floors
i i would remind the member that graphic
stuff like that i have ruled against
before and keep that in mind that that
is unappropriate
i agree mr speaker it is inappropriate
think of the unlucky journalists who
cover the scenes of the unlucky over and
over again the words they write seem
insufficient and the photos just
shockingly familiar
thank you
if the ones left behind are lucky enough
to access mental health care will they
be lucky enough to find someone who can
shine just a little bit of light into
the deep and enveloping pain of the dark
places that survivors are thrust into
some survivors are lucky enough to be
the recipients of meal trains where
friends and neighbors bring food
and even the most lovingly prepared meal
cannot fill the empty place at the table
teachers eva moreless and irma garcia
came to school two days ago to teach
and drew their last breath trying to
protect their students
from the unluckiness
of being in the classroom chosen by a
mass shooter
counting on luck is not good public
policy
the tragedies we see every day show how
the odds are stacked against us and we
need to act
we
have passed gun violence legislation
prevention measures in this house before
not letting our thoughts and prayers get
drowned out by gunfire
it wasn't luck it was hard work
we can do hard things
we need more people to work to make our
community safe from gun violence to lead
to stand up for safe schools and
communities so that teachers
grocery store clerks
and clergy
don't have to defend themselves as if
they are in the theater of war
our schools places of worship stores
concert venues should not be the killing
fields we have allowed them to become
life or death cannot be left to chance
this house
can do hard work
we in this house have the power to
protect innocent lives let's not leave
their fates to chance let's join
together in love and respect for our
fellow new hampshire citizens
to reduce the chance that innocents will
be gunned down in senseless slaughter
we can reduce that chance of tragedy
we can turn around our own luck but only
if we act
thank you senator osborne moves that the
house stand in recess for the purposes
of receiving messages and enrolled
bill's amendments roe bill reports that
the completion of which the house will
stand adjourned to the call of the chair
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those are pros today the eyes have it
the house stands and recess to the call
of the chair
pressure mileage button